SURE. WELL HELLO ONCE AGAIN
GOOD MORNING WELCOME TO THIS
MORNING'S- OVERSIGHT HEARING ON
CALIFORNIA'S ACTIVE SHOOTER
PREVENTION RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY EFFORTS. PLEASE BE
MINDFUL OF THE MASS REQUIREMENT
FOR EVERYONE THIS ROOM AND
MAINTAIN PHYSICAL DISTANCING.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC CAN
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S HEARING
BY CALLING. 977-692-8957 WITH
THE FOLLOWING CODE ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN OR
BY VISITING THE COMPANY'S
WEBSITE AT A E. M. DOT ASSEMBLY
DOT CA DOT GOV. AS WE PROCEED
WITH THE WITNESSES AND PUBLIC
COMMENT ON A MAKE SURE EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS THAT THE SOMEBODY
HAS RULES TO ENSURE WE MAINTAIN
ORDER AND RUN AN EFFECTIVE
HEARING. WE SEEK TO PROTECT THE
RIGHTS OF ALL WHO PARTICIPATE
IN THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE THE EFFECT OF
DELIBERATION AND DISCUSSIONS.
ON THE CRITICAL ISSUES FACING
CALIFORNIA. IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE THESE GOALS WE WILL
NOT PERMIT CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDE THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. IN
ADDITION THIS YEAR WILL BEGIN.
WITH ALSO WE WILL AGAIN BY
COMPLYING WITH ALL PUBLIC
HEALTH ORDERS ARISING OUT OF
THE COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC. DR
SHOOTINGS ARE CURRENT WITH
DISTURBING REGULARITY
THROUGHOUT OUR NATION.
ACCORDING TO THE FBI AMERICA
HAS HAD TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
SEVEN ACTIVE SHOOTINGS WITH
EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR
DEATHS. AND ONE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY SIX PEOPLE
WOUNDED BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
AND TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. ALL
VICTIMS WERE SIMPLY LIVING
THEIR NORMAL LIVES. UNFORTUNATE
CALIFORNIA HAS LED THE NATION
IN ACTIVE SHOOTER EVENTS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WITH SIX.
HAVE ACTIVELY WORKED TO ADDRESS
THE ACTIVE SHOOTING EVENTS IN
CALIFORNIA BY AUTHORIZING AND
PASSING LEGISLATION SUCH AS- AB
FIFTEEN NINETY EIGHT AND TWENTY
THIRTEEN WHICH REQUIRED MUNCHIN
MEDICAL SERVICES AGENCIES. TO
JOINTLY ESTABLISH STANDARD
OPERATING PROCEDURES AND
COORDINATING TRAINING PROGRAMS
FOR ACTIVE SHOOTER INCIDENTS.
AND BABY FOR SEVENTEEN FORTY
SEVEN AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHICH
REQUIRED ALL SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA THEY HAVE A SCHOOL
SAFETY PLANTERS BONTA. JR
CRIMINAL INCIDENTS INCLUDING
ACTIVE SHOOTINGS. AND EVEN WITH
OUR VIGILANCE AND CREATING
GREATER PROTECTIONS. CALIFORNIA
IS NO EXCEPTION TO FACING ACTON
SHOULD EVENTS. AMONG MANY OTHER
TAX WE HAVE LOST OUR COWORKERS
AND THE TWENTY FIFTEEN SAMBAR
DINO ATTACKED. OUR COLLEGE
STUDENTS ARE YOU SEE AS BEING
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THESE LEVELS
TO KILLINGS ARE TSA AGENTS IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN LOS FOUNDERS
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT
SHOOTINGS. OUR FRIENDS AND
FAMILY OF THE TWENTY NINETEEN
GILROY GARLIC FESTIVAL
ATTACKED. OUR CHILDREN AT THE
TWENTY NINETEEN SAUGUS HIGH
SCHOOL SHOOTING. AND OUR
FRIENDS AND FAMILY AT THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BORDERLINE
BOEHRINGER SHOOTINGS
ADDITIONALLY ON MAY TWENTY SIX
THIS YEAR. CALIFORNIA HAD ITS
LARGEST MASS SHOOTING IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WHEN A GUNMAN OPENED
FIRE AT THE SUN WAS A LIFEGUARD.
AND KILLED NINE PEOPLE WE
CANNOT ALLOW THIS TREND TO
CONTINUE. I KNOW THIS SENTIMENT
IS SHARED AMONG EVERYONE HERE
TODAY AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT
THE PANELS SIMILAR ALLOWS TO
IMPROVE HOW WE RESPOND TO THESE
TERRIBLE ATTACKS. AND I HOPE WE
HAVE DISCUSSION WHICH LEADS
CALIFORNIA BETTER PREPARED AND
REASSURED. WITHOUT ON THE FIRST
PANEL WILL HEAR FROM CHIEF
ANTHONY MATA CITY OF SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS. SAN
LUIS OBISPO COUNTY SHERIFF. IAN
PARKINSON CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION ERIC
SAILORS ASSISTANT CHIEF
SACRAMENTO FIRE DEPARTMENT
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION. AND OUR SECOND
PANEL WILL HEAR FROM TOM
OSBORNE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
HOMELAND SECURITY DIRECTOR.
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF MERCHANT
SERVICES MARK HAZEN CHIEF LAW
ENFORCEMENT BRANCH GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
NINETY THE RENDON'S SCHOOL
SAFETY CONSULTING CALIFORNIA
PARMA EDUCATION AND CHIEF JOE
JUSTICE PRESENT A CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE OF UNIVERSITY POLICECHIEFS ASSOCIATION. MIKE
BRADFORD BRO CHIEF TRAINING
PROGRAM SERVICES COMMISSION A
PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING. LUIS BLANCO CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR MERCY MEDICAL
SERVICES THE THIRTY EMSA AND
CRAIG JOHNSON CHIEF DISASTER
MEDICAL SERVICES AND SO. BEFORE
YOU BEGIN WE HAVE ANY OPENING
REMARKS FROM THE VICE CHAIR OR
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
WITH THAT OKAY LET'S BEGIN WITH
OUR FIRST PANEL- LET'S BEGIN
WITH. SAN JOSE POLICE CHIEF
COMPANY MOTHER IS HE AVAILABLE.
IF NOT WE CAN GO AHEAD AND GO
WITH OUR SON WAS OBISPO COUNTY
SHERIFF IAN PARKINSON. SHARE
FOR YOU THERE. GOOD MORNING
JEFF. THE. I THINK HE'S ON MUTE
HOW CAN WE- YEAH. I THINK YOUR
STORE MEET THEIR SHARE OF.
STILL UNABLE TO HEAR CHIFFON OF
YOU HEAR ME. THANK YOU MA'AM.
THE PARTY IS ON. BOB SHORT. I
CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY GO AHEAD
JOBS SORRY ABOUT THAT TECHNO
DIFFICULTIES ON OUR END SO WHEN
YOU'RE READY TO BEGIN- NO
PROBLEM WELL THANK YOU FOR- FOR
HAVING ME COME IN HERE AND
SPEAK- JUST- I'LL GIVE A LITTLE
QUICK CONTACTS AND I KNOW
YOU'RE SHORT ON TIME. OR AT
LEAST- OUR TIME IS LIMITED SO
I'M IN A KIND OF DEFER BACK TO
YOU FOR QUESTIONS OF. THINGS
THAT- I DON'T ANSWER. FIRST
WE'VE IN THIRTEEN MONTHS WE'VE
HAD FIVE SHOOTINGS HERE IN SAN
SAN LUIS OBISPO. THAT'S VERY
UNUSUAL FOR US TO PRICKLY WERE
HAVING A SHOOTING ABOUT EVERY
THREE YEARS- OF THOSE FIVE
SHOOTINGS- TWO WERE ACTIVE
SHOOTERS- THE RESULTS OF THE
SHOOTINGS WE HAD ONE OFFICER
KILLED WE HAD TO BY DEPUTY
SHOT. TWO POLICE OFFICERS
WANTED TO CHP OFFICERS WOUNDED
FIVE CIVILIANS KILLED AND ONE-
ONE INNOCENT CIVILIANS MURDERED.
SO I CAN I CAN TELL YOU THAT
THE TWO SHOOTINGS WERE
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT- ONE- AND
VERY QUICKLY AND ONE TOOK ABOUT
THIRTY SIX HOURS TO RESOLVE-
THE FIRST ONE THE ONE THAT TOOK
THE LONGEST TIME. BEGAN WITH
THE SHOOTER- SHOOTING AT THE-
PASTORALS POLICE DEPARTMENT
BUILDING AT NIGHT THEY OBSERVED
HIM COME UP TO THE DOOR ARMED-
THROUGH CAMERAS. AND THEN- HAD
NOT ONLY HE NOT ONLY BE GET
SHOOTING AT THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT BUT AROUND THE
DOWNTOWN AREA SHOT OUT A- A
FEMALE IN THE DOWNTOWN AREA-
EVENTUALLY MADE HIS WAY UP FROM
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT. AND SHOT
A HOMELESS PERSON- NEAR THE
RAILROAD STATION. AND THEN OUR
OFFICER OUR DEPUTIES ARRIVED
AND- HE AMBER STEM FROM THE
DARK SHOT AT THEM CHANGE
POSITIONS AROUND THE BUILDING
AND THEN SHOT- ONE OF MY
DEPUTIES THAT PRIVACY AND HAD.
A FORTUNATELY NICK IS REVIVED-
HIS PARTNER RETURNED FIRE- HE
DISAPPEARED BACK IN THE NIGHT.
OF HAD A OVER HIDING PLACE THE
FOLLOWING FOLLOWING EVENING HE
REEMERGED WITH THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT RECEIVING A CALL OF
SHOTS FIRED- HE AGAIN- ELUDED
THEM INTO A RIVERBED THE
SALINAS RIVERBED- RE EMERGED A
COUPLE MILES DOWN THE ROAD AT
CHEVRON. YEAH THEY RESPOND
AGAIN HE SHOT. VENTRALLY HE HIT
IN THE RIVER BAD- THE FOLLOWING
DAY MEMBERS OF THE REGIONAL
SWAT TEAM- CAME ACROSS HIM WELL
THEY DIDN'T SEE HIM HE WAS
HIDING. SHOT ONE OF THE
REGIONAL SWAT TEAM MEMBERS IN
THE LAG- EVENTUALLY LEADING TO-
THAT AREA BEING SHUT DOWN HIM
COMING OUT ARMED AND BEING SHOT.
THE SECOND ONE WENT VERY
QUICKLY- GUY TRAVELING FROM
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA ARRIVED
AT A GAS STATION IN APOLLO
CALIFORNIA AND IN MY AREA. AND
WENT TO THE DOOR TO USE THE
BATHROOM HE WAS WITH HIS
GIRLFRIEND. AND THE BATHROOM-
THEY HAD SIGNS ON IT SAYING. IT
WAS CLOSED THIS ANGERED HIM HE
WENT BACK TO HIS CAR- RETRIEVED
THE GUN. GIRLFRIEND FLED THE
CAR AT THAT POINT UNDERSTANDING
THAT HE WAS HAVING A SOME FORM
A PSYCHOTIC BREAK. HE WENT BACK
TO THE OBSERVING CLARK SO I'M
COMING BACK WITH A GUN IT THE
AUTOMATIC DOOR LOCKS HE TRIED
SHOOTING HIS WAY AND IT. DIDN'T
WORK HE STEPPED OUT ONTO A BUSY
ROADWAY- ABOUT TEN THIRTY TEN
FORTY FIVE IN THE MORNING BEGAN
SHOOTING AT CARS- STARBUCKS
CROSS STREET BUILDINGS. ARE AT
END UP SHOOTING A CAL FIRE FIRE
ENGINE RESPONDING TO A CALL-
THREE ROUNDS INTO THE CALGARY
UNFORTUNATELY MISSED. THE
FIREFIGHTERS AND- MADE HIS WAY
BACK AROUND THE BUILDING- THE
DOOR HAD COME OPEN SOMEHOW A-
INNOCENT BYSTANDER HAD GONE
INTO THE BATHROOM OR INTO THE-
BUILDING. HE SAW THEM WHEN IN.
BY THE TIME HE WAS IN IS WHEN
OUR FIRST UNITS ARRIVED OUTSIDE
AND- HE- EVENTUALLY CAME OUT.
AFTER DISCHARGING THE GUN
INSIDE THE- BUSINESS WALKED
OUT- REFUSED TO DROP THE GUN
AND WAS SHOT AND KILLED- SO
THAT ONE HAPPENED VERY VERY
QUICKLY- IT BEGAN AND AT ABOUT-
ONE TWENTY AND ENDED ABOUT
ELEVEN MINUTES LATER. SO TWO
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT SHOOTINGS
FOR US- AND BOTH HAD SIMILAR
HISTORY AND WELL THE FIRST ONE
SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS- IT WAS.
BUT HISTORY WITH THE SHOOTER-
THE SECOND ONE- VERY SHORT
HISTORY OF MENTAL ILLNESS
MATTER FACT NO CRIMINAL HISTORY
NO PRIOR OF VANCE ACTUALLY TRY
TO GO THROUGH POLICE ACADEMY
WAS INJURED SO NO INDICATIONS
THAT HE WAS ANTI LAW
ENFORCEMENT- AND BUT HAD SOME
FORM OF. A MENTAL HEALTH
BREAKDOWN- IN A WEEK OR A
COUPLE WEEKS LEADING UP TO THE
ABOUT. THE QUESTION WAS ASKED
ABOUT OUR TRAINING WE'VE HAD A
PRETTY ROBUST TRAINING PROGRAM
AND AS YOU KNOW SINCE SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE APRIL
NINETY NINE WHEN THE COLUMBINE
SHOOTING HAPPENED IT'S BEEN A
PUSH FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT- SO WE
HAVE HAD ONGOING- ACTIVE
SHOOTER TRAINING FOR OUR
EMPLOYEES BUT ALSO SOMETHING WE
OFFER ALL THE LOCAL POLICE
DEPARTMENTS THE MAJORITY. GO
THROUGH OUR TRAINING COURSE- WE
OFFER- TRAINING AND AWARENESS
FOR ANY BASICALLY ANY GROUP IN
THE COMMUNITY- WE CAN
GOVERNMENT WE DO PRIVATE
BUSINESS- WE'VE DONE CHURCHES.
WE HAVE A FULL PRESENTATION OF
HOW TO PREPARE THEM FOR AN
ACTIVE SHOOTER- WE HAVE A
BIRCHER- USE OF FORCE TRAINING
MACHINE THAT WE USE IN ADDITION
FOR OUR- OUR DEPUTIES FOR
TRAINING. WE PUT TOGETHER A
PRETTY ROBUST. SCHOOL SHOOTING-
PREPARATION. WE PURCHASED A AN
APPLICATION CALLED- RAVE WHICH
IS A BASICALLY AN EMERGENCY
BUTTON- THAT IS AVAILABLE TO
ALL STAFF ON EVERY SCHOOL- WE
HAVE GONE THROUGH AND DIAGRAM
TO- OVER A HUNDRED SCHOOLS IN
OUR COMMUNITY- THAT ARE ALL. ON
A MAPPING PROGRAM THAT INCLUDES
POINTS OF ENTRY- AREAS FOR
EMERGENCY RESPONSE ALTERNATIVE
AREAS FOR EMERGENCY RESPONSE
BUILDING LOCATIONS DESCRIPTIONS
ALL. THAT IS UPDATED ANNUALLY
AND IT'S ALL A PROVIDED TO ALL
THE POLICE DEPARTMENTS AND TO
MY DEPUTIES ON THEIR MOBILE
COMPUTERS IN THE CAR. SO WE- IN
ADDITION TO YOUR AT YOUR YOUR
YOUR NORMAL WORKING WITH THE
SCHOOLS ON PREPARING THEM WE
ALSO SPEND A SIGNIFICANT OUT
AMOUNT OF TIME- ANTICIPATING A
POTENTIAL.ACTIVE SHOOTER TO
SCHOOLS. SO WITH OUR ADVANCE
WHAT WAS UNEXPECTED WELL THE
FIRST ONE BEING THIRTY SIX
HOURS I'M VERY UNUSUAL TO HAVE
AN EVENT GOING THAT LONG. THE
AREA THAT IT OCCURRED IN IS
VERY- ITS BORDER THE TAP
BOARDING THE TOWN AND CAN BE
VERY- REMOTE- EVEN THOUGH WE
FLEW HELICOPTERS FOR ALMOST
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY A DAY-
WITH- FULLER UNITS ON LOOKING
FOR THE SUSPECT HE- ALLUDED BY
BEING IN A STORM DRAIN-
OVERNIGHT. BUT IT WAS A VERY
DYNAMIC- A BAT WHICH REQUIRE
NOT ONLY RESPONSE FROM. ALL OF
OUR AGENCIES IN THE COUNTY
INCLUDING MY SQUAT TEAM THE
REGIONAL POLICE SWAT TEAM. BUT
ALSO- SWAT TEAMS FROM KERN
COUNTY IN KINGS COUNTY ALSO
RESPONDED TO ASSIST IN DAY TO
JUST PURELY BECAUSE OF FATIGUE
AND ALSO THE F. B. I.'S ALEX
WHAT TEAM. I WAS ON GROUNDS AS
WELL. SO WHAT CHANGES HAVE WE
MADE OR WHAT WERE WHAT WE
IDENTIFIED REALLY- A FEW KEY
AREAS THAT NEEDED- NEED WORK.
NUMBER ONE SELF DEPLOYMENT
WHICH SEEMS A SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEM IN MOST MAJOR SHOOTINGS
WHERE AGENCIES RESPOND THEN-
AND YOU'RE UNAWARE THAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE SO COMMUNICATIONS
BECOMES A MAJOR PROBLEM. WHEN
YOU'RE DEALING WITH MULTIPLE
AGENCIES WE FOUND WE HAD TO
HAVE LIISONS WITH EACH OF
THOSE TEAMS- BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T HAVE DIRECT
COMMUNICATION WITH US BUT HE
MEDICATIONS IS DEFINITELY A
PROBLEM AND I THINK ALWAYS WILL
BE. ONE OF THE PROBLEMS THAT I
SAW ONE WHERE IT COMES TO SELF
DEPLOYMENT IS THAT. WE HAVE SO
TRAINED WE'VE TRAINED FOR SO
MANY YEARS AN ACTIVE SHOOTER-
OUR RESPONSES BECOME- I GUESS
VERY- VERY SAD AND THIS
PARTICULAR INCIDENT. WHEN A
SECOND SHOOTING HAPPENED IN THE
SECOND DAY- OFFICERS WERE
COMING IN- FORMING TEAMS AND
DEPLOYING INTO AN AREA THAT WAS
EXTREMELY DANGEROUS BECAUSE OF.
OF COVER AND AYE CONCEALMENT
FOR THE SHOOTER AND REALLY-
LACK OF FAMILIARITY BY THE
RESPONDING OFFICERS AND SO THEY
WERE TREATING IT AS AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER IN ESSENCE GOING INTO A
BUILDING. WHEN IT WAS REALLY
AND AT A POINT WHERE. IT NEEDED
TO BE- THE PRIMER NEEDED RESET
AND THEN A PLANNED RESPONSE
WITH SWAT TEAMS SO ONE OF OUR
BIGGEST PROBLEMS WE HAVE PEOPLE
SOFT POINT INTO. THE HOT AREA-
WITHOUT ANY. WITHOUT ANY
ASSISTANCE OR GOT ANY-
KNOWLEDGE. OF WHAT THEY'RE
WALKING INTO- SO TRYING TO GET
THAT MINDSET- TO YOU KNOW TO
DON'T MOVE IN WITHOUT
DIRECTION- REPORT AND
COMMUNICATE WHO YOU ARE WHERE
YOU ARE- WAS PRETTY VITAL AND
IN THE FIRST- SHOOTING. SO
MOVING FORWARD WITH TRAINING
AND WE FOUND THAT THE REGIONAL-
SWAT TEAM- NEEDS MORE TRAINING
IN AREAS OF LIKE OPEN AREAS
SEARCHING STOP THAT OUR TEAM
YOU KNOW TRAINS ON REGULARLY
BECAUSE OF OUR ENVIRONMENT- AND
THEN AND THEN CERTAINLY-
RETRAINING OF ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL. YEAH AND
I KIND OF THE AREAS THAT I
MENTIONED AND THE COMMUNICATION
RESPONSE. THE ONE THING I
DIDN'T MENTION IN TRAINING WE
ALSO TRAIN WITH- ALL OF OUR
OUR- FIREFIGHTERS- WE TRAIN
THEM IN ACTIVE SHOOTER IN
RESPONSE. ABOUT TEAMING UP WITH
OUR PEOPLE IN RESPONSE- SO-
THAT OBVIOUSLY CONTINUE. IN THE
AREA OF A QUICK MINUTE- BECAUSE
OF OUR SHOOTINGS- WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OR EQUIPPING. OF ALL OF
MY- MARCH UNITS AND ALL ALL OF
OUR STATIONS WITH- PROTECTIVE
SHIELDS- BECAUSE AND IN
PARTICULAR ONE OF OUR SHOOTINGS
THIS LAST YEAR IT WAS A REAL
ISSUE FOR POLICE DEPARTMENT-
LOOKING AT DEPLOYING- OR ARE
MOVING FORWARD DEPLOYING-
HIGHER CALIBER THREE OH EIGHT-
A. R. PLATFORM RIFLES TO. A
SELECTED TRAIN PERSONNEL
BECAUSE IN THAT INSTANCE OF THE
FIRST ONE- WE- WE FOUND THAT
THAT WAS MORE EFFECTIVE THAN
ANY ANY WEAPON THAT WE HAVE.
AND WAS EVENTUALLY- THE THING
THAT ENDED IT. AND THEN OTHR
MISCELLANEOUS EQUIPMENT- EVEN
KNOW WE HAVE REALLY FOUR
ARMORED VEHICLES COUNTY WIDE-
WHAT WE FOUND WAS IS THAT THE-
THE YOU GO THROUGH THOSE VERY
QUICKLY WHEN YOU HAVE A WIDE
AREA SEARCH. AND THEN THE LAST
QUESTION THAT I WAS ASKED WAS
REGARDING ADVICE- AND I WOULD
SAY FOR US IT WAS MAKE SURE YOU
TRAINING WITH MULTIPLE AGENCIES
MAKE SURE YOU TRAIN ON A WHERE
YOUR COMMUNICATION DEFICITS
ARE. HOW DO YOU REPAIR THAT A
SELF DEPLOYMENT- KIND OF BACK
TO THE BASICS- RESPONDING INTO
A HOT ZONE OR MAINTAINING A
PERIMETER ALLOWING YOUR YOU
KNOW TRAIN EXECUTION OF A
PLANNED PARTICULARLY WHEN THE
ACTIVE SHOOTER PORTION IS AND
THERE IS NOBODY NOBODY IN
JEOPARDY IT'S ONE THING
RESPONDING TO A BUSINESS OR A
SCHOOL AND SHOOTING IS STILL
OCCURRING. S. SECOND RESPONDING
TO AN OPEN AREA WHERE THE
SUSPECT IS REALLY HIDING AND SO
I THINK THOSE THINGS BECAUSE OF
OUR ONGOING TRAINING IN THIS
AREA HAVE AB SLIGHTLY GOTTEN
LOST. AND THEN THE LAST THING
WAS IS. WHEN YOU HAVE MULTIPLE
AGENCIES PARTICULARLY YOU KNOW
WITH US WE HAVE SEVEN SMALLER
POLICE DEPARTMENTS WHAT WHAT
WHAT I FOUND IS THAT REALLY
COMMANDED CONTROL- NEEDS TO GET
TRANSFERRED TO THE AGENCY WITH
THE MOST EXPERIENCE. IN THE
AREA- AND THE ABILITY TO- PLAN
AND DEPLOY UNITS- PROPERLY.
STRIP PROBABLY WENT OVER MY
TIME BUT- NOT YOUR FAULT YOU'RE
FINE SURE OF OKAY WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL GO ON TO OUR
NEXT- PANELISTS ON THE FIRST
PANEL I BELIEVE ARE SOME OF THE
POLICE CHIEF OF THE MONTH I
THINK- ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
THIS AREA. A CHAIR CAN CAN YOU
HEAR ME YEAH I'M HERE I THINK
SO OKAY CHIEF RUGGEDMAN READY
CAN GUIDE. YES SIR GOOD GOOD
MORNING- THANK YOU- CHAIR AND-
COMMITTEE FOR- PROVIDED ME HERE
ALONG WITH VEHICLE FOR CHIEFS-
SO I'M GOING TO BRIEFLY SPEAK
UP- TO. INCIDENT THAT HAPPENED
HERE IN SAN JOSE- WE WERE TF
PRIMARY- BEST TO CATER FOR
THIS- INCIDENT. OR OUR
OFFICERS- WE'RE THE ONES THAT
RESPONDED. TO TO THE INCIDENT
HERE IN SAN JOSE SO- ALL
BRIEFLY GO OVER- THE SYNOPSIS
OF- WHAT OCCURRED. SO I MAY-
TWENTY SIX. OF THIS YEAR AT
THE- ALMOST FIVE FORTY THIS
WILL- IN THE MORNING- WE
RESPONDED TO THE- PROBABLY
TRANSIT AUTHORITY WHICH IS A
LOCAL. TRANSIT THAT- AGENCY
HERE IN SAN JOSE. ARE ON A CALL
OF A SHOOTING. WHERE A
MAINTENANCE MECHANIC OF FIVE.
NINE YEARS AFTER BTA- HAD-
BEGAN SHOOTING. INTO TWO
BUILDINGS- AND BIZARRE LOCATION
HAS WAS. YEP BLOCK AWAY. FROM
OUR POLICE TELLS A PLEASE SIGN
HEADQUARTERS. AS WE ARE ABLE TO
RESPOND- IMMEDIATELY- WHEN DID
YOUR CALL CAME OUT- WE LEARN
LATER DETERMINED THAT- THE
INDIVIDUAL. BUT ALSO- SET OFF-
IMPROVISED ON DEVICES AT HIS
HOUSE. FOR HE LEFT- TO WORK
HERE AT THE ALBANY GA YARD
WHICH IS A MINUTE I CAN MENTION
YEAH A MECHANIC YARD HERE-
FORTY PGA- WHEN THE- INDIVIDUAL.
WALKED INTO WORK. HE WENT INTO
ONE OF THE BUILDINGS WHERE HE
PROCEEDED TO WRITE SHOOT THERE
ARE SEVERAL OF HIS COWORKERS-
IN AFTER CHU YANG- THE SHOOTING
THERE IN THAT BUILDING HE WENT
TO A NEARBY BUILDING- ALSO IN
THAT SAME YARD ADVERSITY TO
ISSUE TO OTHER. COWORKERS IN
THAT BUILDING THERE WERE A
TOTAL OF NINE VICTIMS OF THAT
CONDUCT TO- TWO GUNSHOTS- AGAIN
AFTER ACT SHOOTING. OF THIS
WORKERS- THE CAME IN. OUR
OFFICERS- GIVEN THAT WE WERE
CLOSE PROXIMITY. I RESPONDED.
BOB SET UP A- PERIMETER TEAM-
A- REACT TEAM AS WERE TRAINED.
TO HELP ALONG WITH- I BELIEVE
IT WAS- ONE MEMBER OF THE-
CHERTOFF WHO ARE ALSO ARE
RESPONDED AT THAT TIME
IMMEDIATELY- THAT CONTACT TEAM
OF IN. AS OTHER. OFFICERS WERE
ARRIVING ON SCENE ARE THERE
OTHER CON CONTACT TEAMS THAT
WERE BEING ASSEMBLED AND
DEPLOYED. INTO THE BUILDING
WHERE. WE ALL OF THE SHOTS WERE
LAST HEARD SO THOSE TO CONTACT
TEAMS IMMEDIATELY WENT INTO OUT
OF THAT BUILDING- TO WHERE THE
SHOTS WERE WERE AND WHERE WE
KNEW BASED ON INFORMATION- THE
YEAR SUGAR WAS AT. OUR AS A
RESULT OF- THAT. WE BELIEVE
THAT THE- THE INDIVIDUAL KNEW
THAT THE OFFICERS WERE WERE-
WERE ON THEIR WAY. GIVEN THE-
THE SEARCH OF THE BUILDING. AND
INDIVIDUAL ALLOWED TOOK HIS
LIFE- BYE BYE SHOOTING HIMSELF-
WHILE IN THE BUILDING- AS AT
THE SAME TIME THERE ARE OTHER
CONTACTING SOMEONE BEING
ASSEMBLED- THAT WENT INTO THE
INITIAL BUILDING- WHERE. BY THE
YEAR SHOOTER HAD THAT FIRST
BEGAN HIS- THE HIS ASSAULT. AND
AT THAT POINT IS THIS OUT WHEN
NOT BE THAT CONTACT TEAM I
DISCOVERED THAT THE VICTIMS- IN
THAT BUILDING. AGAIN FOR A
TOTAL OF FIVE OF NINE VICTIMS.
AS AGAIN DISTANCE WAS GOING ON-
THE IMPROVISED OUT DEVICES HAVE
GONE OFF- WENT OFF AT HIS HOUSE
I WAS IN A LARGE A STRUCTURE
FIRE. WHICH I HAD A SON. ARE
DEPLOYED IN RESPONSE. I'VE THAT
SCENE TO MAINTAIN THE SAFETY OF
THE COMMUNITY AND ALSO- TO
RESPOND TO THAT INCIDENT AS
WELL- YEAH WE ARE WE WEREN'T
THE BEST A GATING. BY AGENCY-
WHICH IS CURRENTLY A BIG
INVESTIGATIVE BODY SANTA CLARA
COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE. OR I'M
SPEAKING TO HOW. HI IN RESPONSE
THAT WE TOOK- AS- PART ABOUT
THE RESPONSE TO. THE ASSAD'S
ACTIVE SHOOTER INCIDENT- BACK
IN MAY. I WANTED THINGS THAT-
WAS I HEARD ABOUT IT SURE FIVE
MENTIONED. ALSO WAS A SOME OF
THE- CHARGES THAT WE FACED AN
IMMEDIATE. UNIFIED COMMAND.
WITH THAT MEANS IS WHEN WE
ARRIVED TO A SCENE. AT THE STEP
IS SEEN WE KNOW IT IT'S K.
STILL HAS TO TAKE A CHARGE-
FORTUNATELY OUR OFFICERS-
RESPONDED. THAT RESPONDED WERE
ABLE TO FORM THESE- CONTACT
TEAMS AND IMMEDIATELY OR
RESPOND. INSIDE THE BUILDING
WHERE THE SUSPECT WAS HOWEVER
WE ALSO REALIZE THAT IN ORDER
FOR IT TO BE- STRUCTURED- IN A
WAY THAT. AS RESOURCES COMMAND
BECAUSE IT'S QUITE SOUR OR
DISTURBANCES ARE RESOURCE
INTENSIVE WE NEED TO HAVE
SOMEONE. WE LEARNED THAT UP I
LIKE THE TRAINING THAT WE'VE
HAD WE TO HAVE SOMEONE IN
CHARGE IMMEDIATELY TO- MAINTAIN
THAT UNIFIED COMMAND. CHIU US
START DODD DEPLOYING RESOURCES-
AS THE- TRAINING- WE'VE HAD A
ALLOWS- SO SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT- THAT WE'VE DONE HERE AT
THE ECLIPSE AS A POLICE
DEPARTMENT. IS AS SINCE THAT
TWO THOUSAND NINE. I PROVIDED
ACTIVE SHOOTER TRAINING- NOT
ONLY FOR OFFICERS- I DON'T KNOW
WHAT BASIS ARE TOLD FROM NOW-
BUT ALSO- HAD DEPLOYED AND
BEGAN TRAINING WITH OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS SUCH. AS THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT- SO AS A- TWO
THOUSAND NINETY. WE WERE OUT
WORKING WITH AND TRAINING WITH.
OUR LOCAL FIRE DEPARTMENT THAT
STANDS APART APARTMENT. TO
CREATE A TEAM THAT WILL GO IN.
TO TRIAGE SO WE HAVE THE-
REACTING THAT GOES IN AND
ADDRESSES THE ISSUE OF THE
SHOOTER MCKINLEY. AND THEN SOON
AFTER THAT THAT THE YOU KNOW. A
RESCUE TASK FORCE TEAMS- WILL
GO IN AS WELL A TOGETHER WITH
FIRE CHIU- HELP BY ANY VICTIMS
THAT ARE- IN THE IN THE AREA
BECAUSEWE KNOW THAT TIME IS OF
THE ESSENCE- SO WE LEARN FROM-
OTHER AGENCIES ARE. THROUGHOUT
THE- NATION THAT THAT WE NEED
TO PROVIDE IMMEDIATE MEDICAL
SAW SERVICE. TO US SO THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WE ALSO
DEPLOYED. DURING AT THE BEACH
HE SHOULDN'T. AS A RESULT OF
THE UP TRAINING THAT WE'VE-
WE'VE DEVELOPED- SHEARER AND
SETTLES A FOR OUR OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS- SINCE THE COMMISSION
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND NINE.
BEEN TRAINING AND ACTIVE
SHOOTER SO SOME OF THE- TO MAKE
IT AS REALISTIC AS POSSIBLE WE
HAVE THE- THEY BARK- ACTOR
SHOOTER TRAINING SCENARIO- HERE
IN THE IN THIS AREA THE UP AREA
RAPID TRANSIT- ALSO IT AT
LARGE. TRANSPORTATION AGENCY
HERE IN THE US AND I'LL BE
HAPPY SAN JOSE. BACK IN THE-
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE HAD A-
LARGE MULTI JURISDICTIONAL
TRAINING SCENARIOS- WE- PLAYED
TO AN ACTIVE SHOOTER INCIDENT
AT THAT FACILITY AGAIN TO SEE
HOW OUR TRAINING ALIGNS WITH
OTHER AGENCIES ARE RESPONDING
TO THESE TYPE OF INCIDENTS AND
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT- WAS
VERY WELL RECEIVED AND- CAN
HELP LOAN OUR AGENCY BUT- THE-
AVERY AGENCIES TO RESPOND.
AFFORDABLE TO THIS TYPE OF
TRAINING FOR THIS TYPE OF
SCENARIO. ONE OTHER THING-
TRAINING THAT WE'VE DONE. BOB
BAKKEN THAT TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY. ONE IS A SEVERITY HERE
JUST LOCALLY. AT A LOCAL MALL.
WHERE WE TRAINED OUR SPECIAL
OPERATIONS AND- SOME MEMBERS OF
OUR- ACTUAL UNITS TO RESPOND TO
AN ACTIVE SHOOTER AT A MALL. SO
WHAT WE'LL GET TO MAKE IT AS
REALISTIC AS AS POSSIBLE WE-
HAD- THE SCENARIO PLAYED OUT.
AT THAT LOCATION. I WANTED
THINGS THAT- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT. THAT WE DO IS- TO
HAVE MORE REALISTIC TRAINING.
YES IT'S- YOU SEE TWO OF. ARE
SIMPLE TO OUR CONDUCT TRAINING
IN A CLASSROOM BUT THAT WE NEED
TO- GO OUT IN THE FIELD. OF
MUCH LIKE- IN THE PAST WE'VE
DONE- SOME TRAININGS THAT- THE
ESTATE HAS PUT ON- WITH-
SERVICE THROUGHOUT THE
DIFFERENT COUNTIES. I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT- TO DO SO OUR
OFFICERS ARE RESPOND BECAUSE IT
IS LIKE IT IS GOING TO BE. OUR
LINE OFFICER FIRST BOMBS ARE
GOING TO RESPOND. AND IT'S NOT
UNTIL LATER THAT OUR- SPECIAL
OPERATIONS WILL SHOW UP.
BECAUSE OF THE IMMEDIACY OF
THE- SITUATION SO. ANY TRAINING
THAT THAT PROVIDES REALISTIC
INFRASTRUCTURE SCENARIOS- WHAT
WILL HELP THEM IN THAT
TRAINING. AND ALSO BRING IN. AS
A SHARE OF MENTIONS. OTHER
JURISDICTIONS- TO THE TRAINING
SO WE CAN WERE TOGETHER. I
WANTED THINGS THAT WE FOUND- IN
THE MBTA. SHOOTING IS THAT- YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A REGIONAL- RADIO
SYSTEM- HOWEVER- GET WITHOUT
HAVING TO UNIFIED COMMAND UP
MAJORITY OF OUR RESOURCES WERE
SAN JOSE RESPONDING AT THE
TIME. AND THE OTHER
JURISDICTION- HAD- THAT
SWITCHED OVER TO THE- RADIO
SYSTEM THAT WE WERE USING
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DO SO IT WASN'T AFTER AND SO-
ADDS UP A RESURGENT RESPONDED
SO AGAIN HAVING THAT UNIFIED
COMMAND. IMPORTANT TO DIRECT
ALL THE INCOMING RESOURCES ARE
COMING AND SO THAT WE'RE O THE
SAME PAGE RIGHT HERE IN THE
SAME MESSAGE. AND HAVING- THAT
SAME- INFORMATION. OF FOR THE
FIRST RESPONDERS THAT'S ANOTHER
THING THAT WE'VE DONE HERE IN
SAN JOSE. IS NOT ONLY TRAINING
WITH THE FIRE DEPARTMENT BUT
ALSO TRAINING ARE. ORDER UP
MEMBERS END UP IN COMPUTATIONS
SO WE KNOW HOW TO RESPOND. HOW
TO SWITCH OVER TO THOSE OUR
RADIO SYSTEMS. I SAW THAT WERE
ALL. ON THE SAME CHANNEL AND-
UNDERSTANDING. OF INFORMATION
THAT'S- THIS SPRING BEING
BROADCASTED AND BE PROVIDED TO.
THE FRONT LIFESTYLE OFFICER SO
THAT WE'RE ABLE. TO RESPOND AND
LOCATED AT THE INDIVIDUAL. I
WANTED I KNOW THAT- WE ALSO
WHILE WE'RE DISCUSSING HERE IN
SAN JOSE AS WE GO THROUGH THE
TRAININGS- IT IS- WE TALKED
ABOUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE WE
KNOW THAT. THESE INCIDENTS CAN
HAPPEN ANYWHERE. SO WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE IN SAN JOSE IS
CONTACTING US SOME OF THE-
MAJOR- INFRASTRUCTURE SITES OF
A MAJOR SITES- TO WORK WITH
THEM AND TRAIN WITH THEM AS
PART OF THESE. THESE ARE
REALISTIC I TRAINING SCENARIOS.
AND ALSO WHILE GETTING FEEDBACK
FROM THEM. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE ARE CAME UP WITH AND
ARE WORKING TOWARDS. UP
HOSPITALS IN THE MALLS. HOW
MUCH LIKE OF THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT THAT HAS WHEN THE-
ALL UP OR GOING TO A HUGE
CONSTRUCTION. AND YOUR
STRUCTURE THE- PROVIDE
DIRECTION ON HOW TO ACCESS
OTHER BARBECUED ACCESS- THESE
UP THE STRUCTURE TO GET A
STRUCTURE FIRE WELL I THINK WE
NEED TO- WORK WITH. A MAJOR.
BOB STRUCTURE- INFRASTRUCTURES
HERE IN OUR CITIES- TO. OBTAIN
THAT THAT SAME INFORMATION LIKE
PLANS ON THE WAY OUT OF THESE-
THESE BUILDINGS. ARE WHO HAS
KEY CARD ACCESS WHERE WE GET
KEYS. ARE TO HAVE ACCESS-
SOMETHING THAT WE CALL THE- GO
BACK SO. THOSE BAGS- WHERE. THE
FIRST RESPONDERS CAN'T GO INTO
A BUILDING SAY- A LARGE-
TELECOMMUNICATIONS CENTER. SUCH
AS CISCO OR EBAY HERE ARE LARGE
HOSPITAL. AWARE FIRST
RESPONDERS POLICE OFFICERS AND
PACIFIC LEE. AND GO AND GET ALL
THAT INFORMATION ON TO LAY OUT
AND DIAGRAM. OF FIVE THIS THESE
ARE STRUCTURE SO WE CAN BETTER
ABLE MOVER- THROUGH THE SURFACE
ELOISE WHEN WE HAVE THESE THAT
TYPE OF UP INCIDENTS SO. THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THAT WE'RE
WORKING OUT HERE- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT- WAS MENTIONED BY
BISHOP AS WELL AS- YOU KNOW
SOME OF THE NEEDS- I THINK THAT
WILL HELP BY LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AGAIN IS-
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
AND TRAINING AT THE AT THE
STATE LEVEL. AS WE CONTINUE-
WITH THE SILO. WITH THIS TYPE
OF TRAINING BECAUSE WE KNOW WE
SEATED- NATIONWIDE- AT SCHOOLS-
AND- HERE AT THE- AT SOME OF
OUR UP MASS TRANSIT- AGENCIES
BUT IT CAN HAPPEN ANYWHERE SO
WE NEED. TO HAVE MORE REALISTIC
TRAINING- AND RESOURCES FOR OUR
OUR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
PARTNERS WHAT IT IS I ALSO
FORGOT DO YOU WANT TO MENTION
IS- THIS IS SO. RESOURCE
INTENSIVE SO WE DID THAT WORK
WELL WITH- ARGUE AGENCIES SUCH
AS THE FBI- WAS WAS-
INSTRUMENTAL AND ATF-
RESPONDING TO ASSIST HERE IT IS
THAT WE HAVE HERE. IN SAN JOSE
AS WELL AS SAID IN A CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL THEY WERE OUT
THEY ALSO RESPONDED- AND WE'RE
PART OF THE JOB. BOB MACK TEAMS
THAT WE HAD AND THEN ALSO WAS
VERY- AND- FORM AND- INSISTED
AS WELL AS THE COUNTY-
YESTERDAY I WAS ON A SHERIFF
PROPERTY- SEARCHERS SECTION AND
THE UP. WHERE THE INVESTIGATING
AGENCY IT ALSO RESPONDED WITH
THEM- A GREAT PARTNER BARS WAS
THE- CHECKER DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
OF WHERE THEY OPENED A
REUNIFICATION CENTER FOR THE
FAMILIES AND ASSISTED- WITH- ON
THE VICTIM'S FAMILIES- IF ANY
RESOURCES AT THAT WERE
AVAILABLE TO. PROVIDE THEM OUT
OF THE INFORMATION AS IT WOULD
IT BECAME AVAILABLE SO AGAIN
BRINGING ALL THOSE RESOURCES
TOGETHER ARE WORKING TOGETHER
OUT ASSEMBLY TRAINING THAT
WE'VE HAD- HELPED US. IN THIS
AREA- I THINK THAT'S ALL- BY TO
GET A MENTAL PROCESSES SHARP
MENTIONED HAVING THAT COMMAND
CONTROL WHICH IS PART OF THAT-
YOU KNOW- BY COMMAND INITIALLY.
REPORT OUT FOR OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS WHEN THE THESE TYPE
OF INCIDENTS OCCUR. WITH THAT
OUT OF YOUR PROTECTIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH JIM FOR
APPRECIATED- FUNDING WILL GO
OUT TO OUR LAST PANELIST ON
THIS FIRST PANEL OF THIS YEAR
FROM ASSISTANT CHIEF ERIC
SAILOR FROM SACRAMENTO FIRE
DEPARTMENT. CHIEF ARE YOU THERE.
I AM THERE. MIGHT COME A LONG
CLERK YES IN HERE. GOOD THIS
CALL IS A FALSE ALARM YOU SHARE
MY SCREEN I HAVE SOME PICTURES
I CAN PUT UP THAT'LL BE MUCH
MORE INTERESTING LOOK AT THEM
IN OUR THANKS SO. YEAH I
BELIEVE YOU CAN. SHE LOOKED.
OKAY STILL RESULT IN THE
PROGRESSION OF THE FIRE SERVICE
AND SPECIFICALLY WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED IN THE SACRAMENTO
REGION WILL SAY THAT SACRAMENTO
CITY FIRE DEPARTMENT KIND OF
WAKE UP CALL IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
WHEN WE HAD A- A MASS STABBING
AND FOR THE CAPITAL ON THE
CAPITOL GROUNDS WE LOOK TO THE
PHOTO TO LEFT- THAT'S OUR
FIREFIGHTERS TREATING VICTIMS
OF THE THREATS OWN- COVERED BY
POLICE WE KNEW AT THAT POINT WE
NEEDED TO CREATE A VISION WHERE
WE DID BETTER AFTER THIS TYPE
OF COORDINATED EVENT- WE JUST
BACKED UP SERVICE OUR MISSION
IS SIMPLE- SOMEBODY NEEDS TO
STOP THE KILLING AND WE NEED TO
STOP THE DYING. THESE ARE TWO
MISSIONS THAT RUN TOGETHER.
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND FIRE.
SO WE STARTED WHAT IS NOW
CALLED THE THREAT STUDY IT IS A
OVER TWO YEARS WE DID OVER A
HUNDRED TWENTY DRILLS. IN REAL
LIFE- OFFENSE WITH A REAL LIFE
PEOPLE AND IN. PLACES LIKE
NIGHTCLUBS IN BUILDINGS THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO USE IN THE
DOWNTOWN AREA. THE THREAT STUDY
IS AN ACRONYM FROM THE HARTFORD
CONSENSUS WHICH LISTS OUT THE
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO REACH- IN ONE
OF THESE EVENTS SO. D. AS
WORDPRESS OPPRESSION OF ONE
PORTIONS JOB H. IS FOR IMAGE
CONTROL. R. S. RAPID
EXTRICATION AND IN A IS FOR A
STUDENT TEACHER TRIP
TRANSPORTES OF THE BASIC
OBJECTIVES YOU'RE TRYING TO
REACH ONE OF THESE EVENTS. AND
OUR GOAL WAS TO DEVELOP TACTICS
THAT. THAT SO WE HAVE TO PUT
TOGETHER A TEAM OF MIXED OF
ACADEMICS AND SPECIAL FORCES
OPERATORS TO READ EVERY ACTION
REPORT ALL THE ARTICLES WE FIND
GUIDELINES SO WE CAN START TO
ESTABLISH SOME BASIC
TERMINOLOGY AND PUT TOGETHER A
GOOD ACADEMIC STUDY WHERE WE
ACTUALLY MEASURE THINGS AND SEE
IF WE CAN GET IMPROVEMENTSONE
OF THE FIRST THINGS THAT WE DID
AS WE STARTED OUTLINING SOME
USEFUL TERMINOLOGY FOR US. LIKE
MOST YEARS DICTION SACRAMENTO
HAS A PRETTY GOOD MIX OF
AGENCIES SO WE CAN HAVE YOU
KNOW REAL QUICK INTERACTION
WITH CHP SACRAMENTO POLICE
DEPARTMENT SECOND THE SHERIFF'S
OFFICE WESPAC PD- DHS OFFICERS
AND SECRET SERVICE IN THE
DOWNTOWN CORE ANYTIME SO TWO
LINEOUTS AND BASIC TERMINOLOGY
THAT WAS USEFUL FOR US. THE
FIRST THING THAT WE CAME ACROSS
WAS THE- TERM SECURE WE FOUND
THROUGH THESE DRILLS THAT THERE
WAS A LOT OF CONFUSION BETWEEN.
WHAT IT MEANT- WHAT WHAT A LOT
OF FIREFIGHTERS TO GO INTO
THREAT SOUNDS AND- SO WE'RE
USING THE WORD SAVE SOME WHOSE
NETWORK CLEARED- WE CAME TO THE
TERM SECURE. AND WE JUST FOUND
THIS TO RESEARCH SECURE FOR US
MEANT THE ABILITY TO RETURN
EFFECTIVE FIRE SO FROM THE
FIREFIGHTERS PERSPECTIVE IF
THERE'S A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER IN THAT RUMORS OWN THAT
IS ABLE TO RETURN BACK TO FIRE.
THAT UP WHAT WE'RE WILLING TO
GO AND IF THE THREAT HAS BEEN
SUPPRESSED OUR JOB IS TO GET
THE VICTIMS. WE KNOW THAT WE
ARE UP AGAINST THE CLOCK ON ALL
THESE EVENTS SOUND THE GOALS TO
GET ANY VICTIM TO THE HOSPITAL
AND FORTY FIVE MINUTES. ON THE
NEXT TERM THAT WE REALLY
STRUGGLED OVER WAS DIFFERENCE
WHEN VICTIMS IN PATIENTS. THESE
EVENTS THE EVERYBODY IS A
VICTIM- THEY CAN TRANSITION TO
PATIENTS ONCE THEY GET OUT OF
THE THREATS OWN. PATIENTS GET
TREATED TRIAGED AND TRANSPORTED
WHERE'S VICTIMS THEY GET RAPID
BLEEDING CONTROL NEGATIVE TO
THE EFFECTS ON ONCE WE
ESTABLISH THAT TERMINOLOGY FOR
THE FIRE SERVICE BECAME MUCH
EASIER TO FOCUS ON OUR GOALS
WHICH IS TO. GET THE VICTIM OUT
OF THE THREATS OWN IMPROPER FOR
TRANSPORT. WE KNOW THAT ROUGHLY
50% OF OUR VICTIMS ARE TO PUT
IT OUT IN THE FIRST FIVE
MINUTES SO THE GOAL TO GET TO
THEM TO STOP THE BLEEDING AND
MOVE INTO THE EFFECTS ON AS
FAST AS POSSIBLE. WHEN IT COMES
TO THE ZONE OF OPERATIONS WE-
WE HAVE ALL BEEN OUR
TERMINOLOGY. WE FOUND THAT- THE
HOT AND COLD STONES WERE
CONFUSING FOR BOTH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND FIRE IN THE
MEETING THAT. BOTH DIFFERENT
AGENCIES HAVE DIFFERENT
SETTINGS WITH A MUCH SO WE WENT
BACK TO THE ORIGINAL
TERMINOLOGY INTO TRIPLE C. TO
TRIPLE C. IS TACTICAL COMBAT
CASUALTY CARE. THAT WAS A
DOCUMENT PUBLISHED BY THE
MILITARY THAT BASICALLY
OUTLINED A LOT OF OUR TACTICS
NEWS EVENTS- THE RESULTS FROM
KNOWLEDGE IS DIRECT THREAT
INDIRECT THREAT AND HE BACKS
DOWN. WE USE THOSE TERMS IT
BECAME VERY CLEAR TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND FIRE IN OUR
TRAINING. WHAT THAT METRIC
THREAD DRAWS LINE OF FIRE
THAT'S NOT WERE ONE THOUSAND
WERE FIRE GOES FAR IT IS GOING
TRICK FOR OWNS. BUT THEY GO IN
INDIRECT FOR ITS OWN. WITHIN
GET THE VICTIMS THANK AT THE-
AND VICTIMS OUT OF. AREA FAST.
TO BACKS THEM LEAVE EGGS IS
WHERE WE TO BRING A AMBULANCE.
AND GET THOSE PATIENTS OR
VICTIMS TO THE HOSPITAL- AND
LIKE I SAID. OUR GOALS FORTY
FIVE MINUTES. THE RESOLVER HERE
OKAY THERE WE HEAR GOOD THANK
YOU OKAY FANTASTIC. SO DO THE
STUDIES- WE SHOULD WE USE REAL
LIFE VICTIMS AND AT TIMES UP TO
FIFTY M. AND WE FOUND OUT THAT
THE FAR SERVICES REAL PROBLEM
SPACE IS ACTUALLY MOVING
VICTIMS FROM THE THREAT ZONE
INTO THE IMPACTS ON THIS IS A
PHOTO OF US- STAGING ROUGHLY
FIFTY VICTIMS THAT ARE GOING TO
GO INTO. A REAL LIFE NIGHT CLUB
IN THE DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO
COURT WHERE WE USED DJS TURN
OFF LIGHTS WE BASICALLY RAIN
ACT AT THE PULSE NIGHTCLUB. WE
FOUND THAT- LAW ENFORCEMENT WAS
AMAZING THEIR JOB THEY SUPPRESS
THE THREAT VERY QUICKLY IN
THESE DRILLS- FIRST OF SUCH A
HARD TIME MOVING VICTIMS IN A
TIMELY MANNER WHEN THE NUMBERS
GOT HOT. IN THIS TRIAL WE LIKE
SAID WE HAD OVER FIFTY LIVE
PEOPLE IN THEIR TWENTY SIX IN
THE NEEDED TO BE. MOVED OUT
MANUALLY AND PREPPED FOR
TRANSPORT. THAT'S WHEN WE
STARTED TO ADJUST OUR EQUIPMENT
IF YOU LOOK DOWN ON THE BOTTOM
RIGHT HAND CORNER YOU'LL SEE
WHAT IT'S CALLED FOXTROT. THIS
IS THE BASIC TRACKS FLOOD. THIS
ALLOWS US TO MOVE PEOPLE OUT OF
THAT AREA QUICKLY. WE WANT TO
THESE FOR EVERY RIG IN THE-
SACRAMENTO FIRE DEPARTMENT. OUR
NUMBERS DROP SIGNIFICANTLY OUR
TIME FRAMES DROP SIGNIFICANTLY
WHEN WE STARTED USING THESE TO
QUANTIFY THAT. WE'RE ROUGHLY
FORTY FIVE MINUTES TO GET
VICTIMS OUT OF THE BUILDING. IF
MANUALLY WITH JUST FIREFIGHTERS
TO GET TO PERSON KERRY OR IN A
DIAMOND FORMATION. WHEN WE PUT
THE FOXTROT IN THE PLAY. WE ARE
TIMES WENT FROM FORTY FIVE
MINUTES TEN TO TWELVE MINUTES.
WHICH IS VERY FAST. NUMBER
ALTERNATE GOALS TO GET ONE OF
THESE VICTIMS TO SURGERY IN
LESS THAN FORTY FIVE MINUTES.
SURGERIES WHAT TRULY SAVES
THEIR LIVES. SO WHEN WE'RE UP
AGAINST THE CLOCK. GETTING THEM
OUT OF THE OF THE EXCELLENT
FAST IS KEY. WE KNEW THAT WE'RE
MAKING PROGRESS WE STARTED
SEEING OR TIMES DROP DOWN. INTO
THE TWELVE MINUTES ON. THIS
PARTICULAR DRILL HERE AT THE
NIGHT CLUB IN SACRAMENTO OKAY.
WHERE WE HAD OVER FIFTY PEOPLE
IN THEIR TWENTY SIX PEOPLE CAME
OUT ON THE STREET. IN ABOUT
SEVEN MINUTES WITH THE FOXTROT.
REPRINTS FORTY EVERY VICTIM TO
THE HOSPITAL WITH THE DOWNTOWN
AMBULANCES IN TWENTY SIX
MINUTES. WHICH MEANT THAT WE
WERE NOW HITTING OUR OBJECTIVES.
USING SOME DIFFERENT TOOLS. WE
A LOT FROM THE DRILLS. AND WE
TRULY DIDN'T LIKE A SCIENTIFIC
EXPERIMENT. MEANING THAT
OBSERVE MEASURED AND- WE HAD
PROCTORS AT EVERY CORNER OF
RECORDING DATA HOW QUICKLY
FIREFIGHTERS BACK INTO THE ROOM
WHEN TOURNIQUETS WERE APPLIED
WHEN CHEST DEALS WERE APPLIED.
IN THE AND HOW QUICKLY THE
VICTIMS WERE MOVED OUT ONTO THE
STREET. BY MEASURING EVERY
ASPECT OF THIS THAT ALLOWED US
TO REALLY HONE OUR TACTICS. AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
LEARNED. BY GOING TO THIS WAS
THAT THE- RESCUE TASK FORCE
THAT A GREAT JOB OF GETTING US
INTO THE THREAT ZONE. IT IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO MOVE VICTIMS
OUT IN THE STANDARD TIME IN
FORMATION. LEFT INSIDE OF THE
SCREEN. YOU'LL SEE THE BASIC
PLAYBOOK OF RESCUE TASK FORCE
WHICH IS THREE TO FOUR
FIREFIGHTERS REST ARE ESCORTED
IN BY LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
VICTIMS. AND A DIAMOND
FORMATION IT DOES A GOOD JOB OF
GETTING PEOPLE IN. BUT IT'S
VERY HARD TO GET VICTIMS OUT IN
THAT FORMATION WE KNOW THAT
NOW. THAT THE CREW OF FOUR
FIREFIGHTERS CAN EASILY PULL
OUT FIVE VICTIMS THEY MAX OUT
AT ABOUT TEN VICTIMS SO IF YOU
HAVE A HIGH NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
IN A BUILDING OR ZONE YOU HAVE
TO BRING IN A HIGH NUMBER OF
FIREFIGHTERS. SIMMERED BETWEEN
TWELVE TO TWENTY. WE RECOGNIZE
THE DRILL THAT. WE EVERYTHING
WE UP IN A POOR SO COULD START
OFF IN A DIAMOND. BUT WE ALWAYS
WOUND UP IN A SECURE CORE PLAN
VICTIMS OUT. SO WE SAID WHY
DON'T WE JUST START LIKE THAT.
IF LAW ENFORCEMENT SUPPRESSES
THE THREATEN SET UP TO SECURE
CORRIDOR ESCORTS AT SPIN. WILL
BE MUCH FASTER MEMBERS OPENLY
WHERE WE WOUND UP. IN ABOUT THE
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY WHICH WAS
USING LAW ENFORCEMENT TO SET UP
SECURE CORRIDOR BRINGING IN
FIREFIGHTERS IN HIGH NUMBERS-
WITH THEIR FOXTROT TO REMOVE
VICTIMS. AND THAT'S WHEN WE
GOT. VERY FAST WE TRIED THIS.
TACTIC WITH MULTIPLE AGENCIES
INCLUDING CHP. WE DO TO TEACH
HER D. AV DHS DRILL AT CALPERS
IN DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO. AND OUR
TIMES WERE VERY FAST WE HAD
FIFTEEN LINE VICTIMS OUT ONTO
THE STREET. IN SIX MINUTES- SO
IT IS SIMPLE ENOUGH TO SET UP
SECURE QUARTER OR- TO MOVE
THESE VICTIMS OUT. THIS IS A
REAL SIMPLE PRE OUT ON WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED SUCKING REACHING
AND THE PROGRESSION THE FIRE
SERVICE. WE THROUGH OUR
OBSERVATIONS WE KNOW ONE PERSON
IS VERY EFFECTIVE AT
SUPPRESSING THE THREAT NOW. ARE
QALINGE IS. GETTING INTO THE
THREAT ZONE CONTROL IN THAT
MEETING AND THEN GETTING
VICTIMS TO THE HOSPITAL IN LESS
THAN FORTY FIVE MINUTES IF OUR
TACTICS ARE TOO SLOW. AND IT
TAKES US AN HOUR TO GET PEOPLE
OUT OF THE BUILDING- THEN WE'RE
NOT MEETING OUR OVERALL MISSION
WHICH IS STOPPING THE TIME.
THROUGH THESE DRILLS AND WE
STILL CONDUCT THEM- AT TACTICAL
VILLAGE THAT SPD SACRAMENTO
POLICE DEPARTMENT TRAINING
FACILITY WITH ALL THEIR
RECRUITS AND FIRE- WE'VE
LEARNED WE'VE GOTTEN FASTER AND
COLLABORATING WITH MULTIPLE
AGENCIES HAS TAUGHT US A LOT TO
USE THOSE BASIC TERMS. OF
SECURE VICTIM VERSUS PATIENT IN
THAT DIRECTORY INDIRECT
THREATS- WITH THOSE WE ARE NOW
MEETING OUR MISSIONS IN OUR
DRILLS WE'VE HAD TWO ACTIVE
SHOOTERS RECENTLY IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA- AND THEY WENT
VERY SMOOTH BECAUSE WE WERE
ABLE TO USE THIS TERMINOLOGY.
AND THE AGENCIES AROUND THIS
HAVE TRAINED WITH US AND WE'VE
GOTTEN BETTER KNOWN. THAT IS
GOING TO. FOR THE STOCK RE. BE
PREPARED QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- CHIEF APPRECIATE
THAT THANK TO ALL THE PANELISTS
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION AND
TESTIMONY BEFORE YOU OPEN IT UP
TO MEMBERS QUESTION A COMMENTS-
JUST WANNA. SPECIALLY THANK
CHIEF MONTH ON SHERIFF
PARKINSON THANK YOU AND YOUR
MEN AND WOMEN FOR ALL THE HARD
WORK YOU DO DAY IN AND DAY OUT
SO JUST WANTED TO SHARE THAT
WITH YOU SO WITHOUT ANY
COLLEAGUES MEMBERS ARE
QUESTIONS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KOREA QUESTION COMMENT. THANK
AND THANK YOU. TO THE PALACE-
AND YOUR EXPERTISE BUT ALSO THE
WORK YOU'VE DONE- WE ALWAYS
WANT ME. HOW THE SHOOTING SEVEN
SEAT AROUND THE COUNTRY- YOU
YOU ALWAYS HOPE IS NOT YOUR
HOME TOWN AND ON FORCING WITH
THE VTA SHOOTING A WAS AND- SHE
COULD NOT- WAS. CHEN HAD BEEN
CHIEF AT THAT POINT DOESN'T
JUST LESS THAN A HANDFUL MONTHS
AND- HIS LEADERSHIP AND
LEADERSHIP AND- THE QUICK
ACTION. OF AS HE INDICATED
MULTI JURISDICTIONAL RESPONSE.
RESPONSE WAS CRITICAL THAT DAY
BUT I THINK TO HIS POINT OF
THIS OF THE COMES UP AND HAS
COME UP OFTEN AND I'M AND I'M
SURE- VICE CHAIR HAS WHAT IS A
LOT OF EXPERTISE IN THIS IS THE
COMMUNICATIONS- ASPECT OF NOT
BEING ON A SINGLE CHANNEL- A
NUMBER IS REALLY KEEN I THINK
OF THAT. THAT YOU KNOW THAT
SOMETHING THAT- WE'VE HEARD
BEFORE RIGHT AND I THINK IT'S
GONNA BE A TAKE AWAY THAT WE
CAN'T JUST WALK AWAY FROM THIS
MEETING AND- AND LEAVE ON THE
TABLE- BECAUSE WE SEE IT TIME
AND AGAIN UNFORTUNATELY. EVERY
TIME THERE'S A SHOOTING-
INFORMS US WELL WE'VE BEEN
EDUCATED MORE THAN WE'VE EVER
WANTED TO- OVER THE LAST FEW
FEW A FEW YEARS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. BUT I THINK THAT MESSAGE
I THINK IN EVERY ONE OF THESE
INSTANCES KEEPS COMING UP. IS
THAT UNIFIED WE HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY IS WE HAVE THE
UNIFIED TOGETHER AND SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE SHE BOUGHT
THE FOR REITERATING THAT-
BECAUSE I THINK- YOU KNOW BUT I
THINK. THAT THAT'S WHERE AN
INTO A- THE CCI SAILORS. IN OF
MAKING SURE THAT YOU CAN PEOPLE.
WITH ALL THAT. IT'S ALL ABOUT
WHAT HOW COULD PROCESS COULD BE.
AND THAT THE SITUATION. IS AT
LEAST THE BEST OF. THE BEST
ABILITY POSSIBLE EITHER
COMPLETELY NEUTRALIZED OR AT
LEAST ISOLATED SO THAT- SHE
SAILORS AND HIS MEN AND WOMEN.
CAN GET THE FOLKS AND GET HIM
TO THE HOSPITAL SO I THINK
THAT- I REALLY APPRECIATE. YOU
HOLDING THIS HEARING BUT I
THINK THAT MEANS A LOT WE CAN
TAKE FROM THIS THAT. I LOOK
FORWARD TO FOLLOWING UP ON
THANK YOU. THANK VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF VULTURES AE
OUT TO YOUR QUESTION. ACTUALLY
I DO HAVE QUESTIONS AND ALSO
THE MAIN QUESTION IS AS A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA IS
POINTING OUT IS. WE NEED TO
TAKE SOMETHING OUT HERE THAT WE
CAN DO TO HELP MAKE THESE
THINGS BETTER. AND FROM THE
STATE'S PERSPECTIVE THAT MEANS.
MAKING SURE THAT WE DO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE- INVESTMENTS
THAT WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT.
OUR TECHNOLOGY IS UP TO SNUFF
AND- AND THE BIGGEST ISSUE IS
AS IS POINTED OUT HIS
COMMUNICATION. AND THE- SAN
LUIS OBISPO SHERIFF'S. THE TALK
ABOUT THIS LITTLE BIT- BEYOND
THE INTEROPERABLE IT ISSUE
WITH. WITH OUR RADIOS ARE
PORTABLE RADIOS. IT IS BEEN
GOING ON FOR I THINK THE EFFORT
HAS BEEN A BIG PUSH FOR THE
LAST DECADE AND A HALF AT
LEAST. AND IT I DON'T KNOW WHAT
IS A TRAINING ISSUE STILL OR
THE TECHNOLOGY IS STILL
STRUGGLING OR WERE HAVING
TRANSMISSION TOWER ISSUES AND
WE'RE WE'RE NOT HAVING ENOUGH.
WE HAD A BIG SWITCH IN BAND
WITH- ABOUT I THINK IT WAS SIX
OR SEVEN YEARS AGO AND- WHICH
WOULD REQUIRE MORE- CELL TOWER
OR- BED TOWER INFRASTRUCTURE TO
BE PUT UP ON A BECAUSE YOU'RE
GOING TO A SHORTER WAY. WHAT IS
THE PROBLEM WITH COMMUNICATION
IS IT BOILS DOWN TO DISCIPLINE
OR IS IT. IS IT INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT THAT'S NEEDED HOW
CAN WE HELP. YOU MAKE THAT
COMMITMENT THAT COMMUNICATION
ISSUE BETTER BECAUSE THAT IS
THE WHOLE KEY TO. IF YOU ARE A
INCIDENT COMMANDER AND YOU
DON'T HAVE COMMUNICATION THEN
YOU'RE INCIDENT IS CHAOS. SO
ANY OF YOU GUYS CAN HELP ME
WITH THAT BECAUSE- IF THERE'S
SOME ISSUES THERE THAT WE NEED
TO INVEST. THEN CERTAINLY
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
WE SHOULD START LOOKING AT
DOING. MORE OF. SURE I CAN I
CAN START HERE AND ON OUR END
HERE IS AT. THE INTER
OPERABILITY IS WORKING WHILE
YOU'RE A SUCKER COUNTY- AND I
KEEP MATCH IS ALWAYS BEING
UPDATED- SO FOR US IT'S MORE.
MORE ON THE TRAINING SIDE- HOW
TO. HOW TO DEPLOY IT ONE SIDE
THESE- EXISTENCE I KNOW WE WERE
ALL SET TO GO TO A CHANNEL.
AGAIN IT'S- HAVING TO UNIFIED
COMMAND. TO SET THOSE TRIGGERS-
OR TO DIRECT INCOMING RESOURCES
AS TO WHAT TO DO- BUT- I THE
INFRASTRUCTURES THERE. AND IT'S
BEING UPDATED CONSTANTLY.
HOWEVER AT THIS IS YOUR
MENTIONS IT FOR US IT COULD BE
A DURING HIS TRIP. TO ENSURE
THAT. WE'RE ON THE SAME CHANNEL
AND- WE HAVE THIS RIGHT TODAY
SEKHON PLANS FOR YOU GUYS
BEFORE WELL YOU'RE RESPONDING
TO THE INCIDENT SO THAT YOU
HAVE A COMP PLAN WHEN YOU GET
THERE- BECAUSE THAT IS THAT IS
ONE OF THE THINGS WE FOUND
REALLY HELPFUL- IN THE COUNTY
WAS IN L. A. COUNTY WAS. AT
HAVING A COMP PLAN BEFORE WE
EVEN GOT ON SCENE- THAT THE-
THE INCIDENT COMMANDER WOULD
ALREADY REQUESTED AND HAVE IT
SO EVERYBODY HAD IT ON THERE
INDICATE. THAT WHAT THE COMP
PLAN WAS. WELL TO CHECK IS IF
YOU HAVE OF THOSE BY THE I KNOW
THAT- I CAN MENTION MAJORITY
OUR RESOURCES ARE COMING IN.
THE SENSE OF WHERE SAN JOSE.
AND WE WERE ALL ON OUR CHANNEL
THERE. NORMAL CHILD FOR THAT
AREA. AND WE ASKED EVERYBODY-
SWITCH THAT CHANNEL AND-
SOMEWHERE AND SO. RIGHT AND FOR
THE SHERIFF FROM FROM SAN LUIS
OBISPO IT WAS ONE OF YOUR-
CHIEF DOWN THERE IN A ROW
GRANDET BELIEVE. WAS REALLY
HEAVY INTO HELPING WITH THIS
INTER OPERABILITY PUSH- IT IS
THE INTER OPERABILITY WHILE
IT'S REALLY GOOD UP AND SAN
JOSE IS IT SOMETHING THAT IS-
CARRYING ON STATEWIDE OR DO WE
HAVE STILL AREAS THAT ARE
DEFICIT IN THIS. WELL I THINK-
I AGREE WITH WHAT THE CHIEF
SAID FIRST- I THINK A LOT OF IT
IS. IS EITHER OPS PLAN OR- YOU
KNOW TRAINING. BORE US- WE DO
HAVE GOOD INTER OPERABILITY
WITHIN THE COUNTY SO ALL OF OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND WE
DO HAVE AN OFFICE PLAN IN THE
SENSE THAT THERE WHEN THEY
RESPONDED THEY'RE DIRECTED TO
WHAT CHANNEL THEY'RE OPERATING
ON- THERE'S TWO CHALLENGES THAT
I SEE NUMBER ONE. IS WHEN YOU
YOU KNOW WE'VE TAKEN AREA LIKE
SAN JOSE OR EVEN US WHEN YOU
HAVE ALL THOSE AGENCIES YOU
HAVE. YOU COULD HAVE YOU KNOW.
EIGHTY TO A HUNDRED DIFFERENT
PEOPLE ON THE SAME CHANNEL-
WHICH BECOMES AN ISSUE BUT I
THINK WHERE YOU GUYS COULD COME
INTO PLAY AT LEAST FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE IS. IS C. H. P. FOR
EXAMPLE- THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT
OPERATING ON OUR CHANNEL AND
HAVING THOSE CAPABILITIS I
THINK ARE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY. WITH THE
STAGE BE IN OUR AREA ON A DAILY
BASIS WE CAN. EDUCATE RACKLEY
WITH THERE AIRCRAFT BECAUSE
THEY HAVE THAT ABILITY BUT YOUR
BASIC- STAGE BE A TROLL
OFFICER- THAT IS AN ISSUE-
FEDERAL PARTNERS ANOTHER ISSUE
BUT OUR ISSUE IN PARTICULAR OUR
FIRST ONE WAS. IS HAVING
OUTSIDE- COUNTY AGENCIES COME
IN THAT DON'T HAVE- THAT
ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE AND SO
WORKING ON TRYING TO COME UP
YOU KNOW WITH A COMMENT CHANNEL
LIKE FOR. FOR REGION ONE AA-
SAN LUIS SANTA BARBARA AND
VENTURA WE DO HAVE A COMMON
CHANNEL THAT WE CAN OPERATE ON
SO THAT'S FINE BUT AS SOON AS
YOU GO EAST OR NORTH OF US
OUTSIDE OF OUR REGION. THAT'S
WHEN IT BECOMES A PROBLEM BUT I
WOULD SAY THE BIG PUSH IS.
PARTICULARLY WITH THE STATUS IS
GETTING STAGE BEYOND OPERATION
CHANNEL THAT THEY CAN
COMMUNICATE WITH US DIRECTLY IN
THERE YOU KNOW RESPECTIVE
JURISDICTIONS. THANK YOU. FOR
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- WITHOUT
OVERSEE A THE WHOLE POINT
HAVING THIS HEARINGS TO HEAR
SOME OF THIS INFORMATION I
WOULDN'T BE OF HELPFUL OVERSEE
COMMUNICATIONS IS ALWAYS GOING
TO BE KEY FOR ALL OF OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS A SPECIAL AREN'T
RESPONDING TO. THESE DISASTERS
OF ACTIVE SHOOTERS AND NOW WITH
THE FIRES GOING ON BUT I JUST
WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY ONCE
AGAIN FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
AND HELP AND- WILL TAKE A LOT
OF YOUR INFORMATION AND SEE
WHAT WE CAN DO TO HELP YOU-
FROM OUR END- JUST WONDERS-
TALKED IT CHIEF SAILORS ONCE
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR. ALL THAT
YOU DO THERE WHAT THE SEGMENT
OF FARO IS THERE WITH YOU A FEW
MONTHS AGO TO SEE FIRSTHAND
SOME OF THE COMMON YOU HAVE
BEEN AND HOW YOU GUYS
RESPONDING IN TRAINING
EVERYBODY COMES FROM DIFFERENT-
TYPES OF- AREAS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OFFICIER IN SACRAMENTO
WITH THE FIRE DEPARTMENT WE
HAVE THE- THE GOLDEN ONE CENTER
AND WHAT YOU DO TO TRAIN
RESPOND TO THAT. AND IT'S GOOD
TO SEE THAT YOU'RE DOING THOSE
ALSO TRADING IS WITH US SOME OF
THE NIGHT CLUBS IN OFFICE YOU
WITH OUR FOLKS IN SAN JOSE AND
SAN LUIS OBISPO YOUR ERRORS ARE
VERY UNIQUE AND HOW YOU RESPOND
AND WHAT YOU HAVE YOUR
RESOURCES THERE- BUT- DON'T
HESITATE TO REACH OUT TO ME OR
MY OFFICE OR ANY OF THE MEMBERS
HERE WE CAN. BE OF ASSISTANCE
TO HELP YOU AS WE DEAL WITH A
LOT OF ISSUES IN CALIFORNIA BUT
WE ALWAYS WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR FIRST RESPONDERS HAVE
THE NECESSARY TOOLS AND
EQUIPMENT TO RESPOND TO TAKE
CARE OF OUR FOLKS NO MATTER
YOUR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SO ONCE
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING. AND I WILL MOVE
ON TO OUR NEXT PANEL. SO WITH
THAT ARE SICK PANEL WE HAVE. TO
TOM ALSO. OF THE HOMELAND
SECURITY- DIRECTOR GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE EMERGES SERVICES. OF TOM
ARE YOU THERE. I AM VERY
PLEASED TO HEAR ME OKAY YES WE
CAN HEAR FINE. GREAT GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN BUDGET ARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
COLLEAGUES BOB MY NAME IS TOM
OSBORNE NINE THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF HOMELAND SECURITY
DIVISION HERE AT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
FIRST OF ALL YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS CARILLO
YESS ROLE IN PLANNING AND
PREPAREDNESS FOR ACTIVE SHOOTER
INCIDENTS THROUGHOUT. THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AS EVERYBODY IS
AWARE CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITIES
FACE A VAST FOREVER. ARRAY OF
THREATS AND HAZARDS INCLUDING
YOU KNOW CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
DISRUPTIONS CYBER ATTACKS AND
TARGETED. VIOLENCE IT SHOOTER-
INTO. AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
BY GERMAN REFEREE BUT WORTH A
NOTING. THE CORE TO THE FBI TO
HERE STANDARD. HAD COMPUTERS.
YOU KNOW CAL YEAH. ACTIVE
SHOOTER INCIDENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE IN TWENTY TWENTY
ALLOWED SIX ACTIVE SHOOTER
INCIDENTS OCCURRED IN
CALIFORNIA. RESULTED IN FIVE
INDIVIDUALS BEING KILLED IN
TWENTY THREE WERE THE HIGHEST
ON IN THE NATION SOME SOBERING
STATISTICS THERE ARE SOME OF
THINGS LIKE THE HIGHLIGHT OF MY
COUNTY US HELLO YES IS DOING IN
THIS SPACE FIRST AND FOREMOST.
IT IS OUR ACTIVE SHOOTER
AWARENESS GUIDANCE THAT WE
HAVE- PUT OUT PREVIOUSLY AND
CONTINUE TO UPDATE- TO HELP
EDUCATE- A WIDE VARIETY OF
INDIVIDUALS. YOU MAY RECALL THE
ACTIVE SHOOTER INCIDENT THAT
OCCURRED ON DECEMBER SECOND
TWENTY FIFTEEN AT THE END WHEN
REGIONAL CENTER IN SAN
BERNARDINO. FINALLY THAT WERE
RECOMMENDED- AND THIS THE
SUBSEQUENT AFTER ACTION REVIEW
WE DISCOVERED THE INCREASED
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE
AND TRAINING FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH ACCESS AND FUN FUNCTIONAL
NEEDS. TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
HELLO YES BROUGHT TOGETHER A
WORKING GROUP CONSISTING OF
LOCAL PERSONAL MARKETING FROM
UP NORTH THE LOWER EAST. THE
REGIONAL- CENTER'S EMERGENCY.
MANAGERS CALIFORNIA. THE NEW
YORKERS YOUR STAKEHOLDER IN
THIS. WE WERE THE FUNCTION IN
THE EVENT WITH THAT AND FOR
NEEDS SO THAT WE THREE GREW SO
THAT THEY WE WERE- HELP TO MAKE
NATURAIS ONE IN THE WORKFORCE.
INTO THE- AND SMALL INDIVIDUAL
WITH THE ACCESS AND PUBLISHER
NEEDS OF. ONE FOR. THAT'S RIGHT
LION THE PROFILE OF AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER AT AS WE HAVE SEEN MANY
DIFFERENT SUB THERE IS ONE FOR.
THE YOU CAN BUT ON ACTIVE. AND
THIS GUY WE DESCRIBE IT OF A
SHOOTER INCIDENTS AND HOW THREE
DIFFERENT OPTIONS- ACCORDING TO
THE DHS AND DIFFERENT STUDIES
OF OPTIONS TO TAKE DURING AN
INCIDENT YOU KNOW THE RUN HIDE
FIGHT. A MANTRA. THIS ACTIVE
SHOOTER AWARENESS GUIDANCE ALSO
OUTLINES WHAT INDIVIDUAL SHOULD
DO ONCE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ARRIVES. AND THE PURPOSE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S RESPONSE AND HOW
PEOPLE CAN ASSIST IN KENYA
COMMUNICATE WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT DURING. AN
INCIDENT. SINCE THE RELEASE OF
THIS ACTIVE SHOOTER GUIDANCE-
MANY OTHER STATES INCLUDING NEW
YORK AND MASSACHUSETTS HAVE
USED WHAT WE HAVE DONE HERE
CALIFORNIA. TO HELP WITH THEIR-
S. B. THE STATE ACCOUNT. YEAH
ATTY AND IN THE MOST RECENT
JOSH AND NOW DO TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FOUR THERE ARE SOME
AREAS IN THERE THAT ADDRESS-
SPECIFIC THE ACTIVE SHE- THREAT-
IN OUR A COUPLE HERE AS PART OF
THIS STRATEGY FIRST FOREMOST BY
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF THIS
YEAR JALLOH YES THE HOMELAND
SECURITY VISION WILL COMPILE A
LIST OF PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
MATERIALS AND RESOURCES ARE FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO MITIGATE
TARGETED VIOLENCE INCLUDING
ACTIVE SHOOTER EVENTS. ANNUALLY
HELLO YES THE RETIREMENT
SECURITY MEASURES WILL PRODUCE
A WHITE PAPER ON EXISTING LOCAL
VIOLENCE PREVENTION EFFORTS TO
BE MADE AVAILABLE THROUGH OUR
PUBLIC INFORMATION OFFICE AGAIN
DISSEMINATING ALL THE GREAT
WORK THAT'S BEING DONE AROUND
THE STATE LESSONS LEARNED AND
LEARN FROM EACH OTHER. AND
LASTLY I'M PART OF THE HOMELAND
SECURITY STRATEGY WELL SO. OUR
THIRTY FIRST OF THIS YEAR. YEAH
ORDINATION CAL SPECIALIZED
TRAINING. WE WILL A LIST OF.
THAT ARE. TO LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND AGENCIES TO
TRAINING ON DIGITAL MEDIA
LITERATE LITERACY HATE
REDUCTION AND TARGETED VIOLENCE
PREVENTION AND WILL CERTAINLY
MAKE THIS LIST AVAILABLE TO A
WIDE VARIETY OF INDIVIDUALS AND
ORGANIZATIONS TO. TO TO HELP
ADDRESS THIS THIS THREAT. NEXT
MONTH TRANSITION TO OUR GRANT
PROGRAMS CALIFORNIA'S UTILIZES
AN OVERSEAS SEVERAL DIFFERENT
GRANT PROGRAMS- FOR A
PARTICULAR THAT ARE STRAIGHT-
ALIGNED WITH ACTIVE SHOOTER
INCIDENTS THE FIRST ONE I LIKE
TO DISCUSS IT IS A PROGRAM
CALLED STUDENTS TEACHERS AND
OFFICERS PREVENTING SCHOOL
VIOLENCE GRANT. OR NOT WORDS
STOP THIS OF THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE GRANT
WITH THE GOAL OF REDUCING
VIOLENCE IN OUR SCHOOLS
CURRENTLY- OF OVER US AND OUR
PARTNERS ARE UTILIZED IN THE
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
FUNDING TO ENHANCE OUR
CALIFORNIA COMPREHENSIVE.
SCHOOL SECURITY PROGRAM. THE
CALIFORNIA COMPREHEND SCHOOL
SECURITY PROGRAM CONSISTS OF.
ONLY THREE COUNTIES- THAT
INCLUDES SAN DIEGO ORANGE
COUNTY AND NAPA COUNTIES.
COMPONENTS OF THIS PROGRAM
INCLUDE THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF ENHANCED
BEHAVIORAL THREAT ASSESSMENT
AND MANAGEMENT TEAM THAT HAS
WON SHE TO HELP READERS- THE
VIOLENCE THAT IS OCCURRING.
ADDITIONALLY THE UTILIZATION OF
CAMPUS BUILDING AND CLASSROOM
VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENTS- ARE
COMPLETED BY LOCAL FUTURE- THIS
YEAR AND SHE TALKED ABOUT IT AS
SUCH OF ALL OF THEIR SCHOOLS
AND BILL IT'S A THAT THEY HAVE
A MATCH WHEN THEY DO RESPOND
THOSE INCIDENTS. THEY CAN
EFFECTIVELY TARGET WHERE THE
ACTIVE SHOOTER MAY BE LOCATED.
I'M IN ADDITION THIS PROVIDES A-
FOR SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICERS
AND OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
DISTRICT STAFF. THAT PROVIDE
OPTIONS TO ACHIEVE INCREASE
SECURITY AWARENESS PREPAREDNESS
FOR THREATS- INDOOR FACILITY
SECURITY AND TRAINING AND
DRILLS. HELLO YES WILL YOU LIVE
RESULT FROM THESE THREE PILOT
PROJECTS THAT OF THOSE THREE
COUNTIES DEVELOP A STATEWIDE
FRAMEWORK WHICH WILL PROVIDE
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS WITH THE
TOOLS THEY NEED TO RECOGNIZE
RESPOND TO. AND TO HELP PREVENT
ACTS OF VIOLENCE TO ENSURE A
POSITIVE SCHOOL AND SAFE
ENVIRONMENT. THE SECOND GRAND I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT IS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE. GRANT WHICH
IS A STATE SUPPLEMENT TO THE
FEDERAL NON PROFIT SECURITY
GRANT PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES
FUNDING TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
CONSIDERED AT HIGH RISK FOR
VIOLENT ATTACKS AND HATE CRIMES
INCLUDING ACTIVE SHOOTER EVENTS
DUE TO THEIR IDEOLOGY BELIEFS
AND OR MISSIONS. THIS GRANT
PROGRAM FOCUSES ON TARGET
HARDENING ACTIVITIES AND
PHYSICAL SECURITY ENHANCEMENTS
WHICH INCLUDES EQUIPMENT THAT'S
SHOWING UP WITH MILITARY
PERIMETER FENCING ACCESS
CONTROL SYSTEMS CAMERA
REINFORCED DOORS SECURITY
GUARDS AND TRAINING FOR ACTIVE
SHOOTER EVENTS AND ASSISTANCE
WITH THE DEVELOPMENT. OF
EMERGENCY PROCEDURE MANUALS.
THE THIRD IT'S ALSO AVAILABLE
CALIFORNIA HAS COMPLEMENT. IS
CALLED THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
CENTER SECURITY GRANT PROGRAM
WHICH PROVIDES FUNDING. FOR
TUCKER TARGET MARKETING
ACTIVITIES TO NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS THAT
PROVIDE ABORTION SERVICES AND
THEREFORE MAY BE TARGETS OF
VIOLENCE AND VANDALISM AND ALSO
INTRODUCE ACTION SHOOTER A VAST.
FOR AND ONE LAST ON THE GRAND
SIDE HERE IS THE- SCHOOLS
COMMUNICATION IN OUR UP ABILITY
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES FUNDING
FOR ENHANCEMENT INTEROPERABLE
COMMUNICATION TECHNOLOGY THAT
IT WAS LOCAL FIRE AND- IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO CONNECT
SHARE AND COORDINATE WITH
SYSTEMS AND SECURITY TECHNOLOGY
SYSTEMS. INSTALLED AND
OPERATING IN OUR CASE THE.
TWELVE SCHOOLS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AS AS COMMUNITY.
AND IN THE IN THE CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS IN RESPONSE
TO ACTIVE SHOOTER EVENTS IN
ADDITION TO THE TECHNICAL AND
FUNDING SIGN OF THIS THIS GRANT
ALSO. PRACTITIONER OF BROWN'S
IN PLANO ACTIVITIES FOR THE
INTEGRATION OF INCOMPARABLE
COMMUNICATIONS CAPABILITIES
INTO EXISTING BURN STING
OPERATION PLANS AS YOU LOOK
INTO IN THE FIRST PANEL YOU
KNOW EXERCISING AND TRAINING.
THE TECHNOLOGY COMPONENT WE'RE
GETTING MUCH BETTER AND IT'S
THERE IT'S THE TRAINING
COMPONENT- OF HOW AN
INDIVIDUAL'S ARRIVES ON THE
EVENTS HOW TO REACH EACH TALK
TO EACH OTHER IN RESPECT OF
MANNER TO. MAKE. WHAT ELSE- SO
CATER TO SCHOOLS AWARDED FROM
THIS FOR. AND IT BASIC IS
MANAGED THROUGH THE IS-
DEPARTMENTS AND- ALL IN SO
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE GRANT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE MADE
AVAILABLE AND SOME OF THINGS
THAT CALIFORNIA'S IS DOING WITH
ALL OF OUR PARTNERS UP IN THE
STATE'S UP AND DOWN THE STATE-
NEXT I WOULD BE TURNING OVER TO
CHIEF MARK HAZEL. OBVIOUS
HAVING SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES HE IS REMOTE AGAIN
LOS ANGELES A LESSON MARC HAS
JUMPED ON I WILL TALK BRIEFLY
ABOUT THE MUTUAL AID. SYSTEM R.
D. I'M NOT SURE OF MARK GOING
TO MAKE IT BUT WE'RE FINE WITH
THAT. UNLESS HE'S AVAILABLE I
DON'T KNOW IF HE IS AROUND. NOW
LOOKS LIKE HE'S NOT AMONG THEM.
OKAY WELL JUST BRIEFLY TOUCH ON
THAT- SO ON THE ON THE MUTUAL
AID SIDE SO THE SPEECH WHICH
THIS WAS ESTABLISHED IN
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE AND HAS BEEN
USED TO RESTORE ORDER DURING
EMERGENCIES INCLUDING ACTIVE
SHOOTER INCIDENTS AND PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL H. DURING
AND- I'VE USUAL EVENTS. THE
BASIC CONCEPT PROVIDES THAT
WITHIN AN OPERATIONAL AREA
ADJACENT TO OUR NEIGHBORING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WILL
ASSIST EACH OTHER IN A
NEIGHBORING AGENCIES HELPING
NEIGHBORING AGENCIES. SHOULD
THE EVENT REQUIRE ASSISTANCE
FROM OUTSIDE THE COUNTY THE
REGION WILL PROVIDE REQUESTED
ASSISTANCE TO BE IMPACTED
COUNTING. IF THE COMBINED
RESOURCES OF THE REGION ARE
INSUFFICIENT TO COPE WITH THE
INCIDENT THE REGIONAL
COORDINAOR CONTACT THE STATE
LAW ENFORCEMENT MUTUALLY CORNER
AT DENTAL RESPECTFULLY ASK. TO
BRING IN ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
A SIMILAR TO FOR THE COUNTY.
WERE MAY BE AFTER AND I SHOOTER.
PROVIDES ASSISTANCE FROM THE
LAW. TO THE TRI LEVEL. WHENEVER
THINK ABOUT HER TO BE
DEVELOPING WHICH CANNOT BE
RESOLVED BY LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY WITH THE
OPERATIONAL AREA. IT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
OPERATIONAL MUTUAL AID FOR
DINNER WHICH IS THE COUNTY
SHERIFF TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
AND COORDINATION TO CONTROL AND
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM. IN
RESPONSE TO A REQUEST FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT MUTUAL AID BY THE
CHIEF OF POLICE WITHOUT AN
OPERATIONAL AREA THE SHAREPOINT
ISSUE PROCEDURES. TO ACTIVATE
THE MUTUAL AID. SURE YEAH CARE
RESPONSE ALL OF RESOURCES.
THOSE UNAFFECTED OPERAS
OPERATIONAL HERE TO DISMISS
PARODIES INCLUDING LOCAL CHP
ANOTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WITHIN. THE
OPERATIONAL AREA. AS WELL AS
THE SHARE OF RESOURCES IN ORDER
TO ASSESS THE EFFECT OF LOCAL
CHIEF OF POLICE. IF IT APPEARED
AS THOUGH RESOURCES OF AN
OPERATION OF ALL BECOME
DEPLETED. REGIONAL BORDER.
SHOULD BE ADVISED TO GO AHEAD
OF TIME. TO BRING MORE MORE
RESEARCH. THREE COORDINATOR IS
A WALL THAT STILL BY A LOCAL
OFFICIAL IN THAT REGION THAT IS
ELECTED BY THEIR PEERS- AS
MENTIONED ABOVE IF ALL THE
COMBINED RESOURCES OF THE
REGION ARE OVERWHELMED THAT
REQUEST IS MADE UP OF THE STATE
TO BRING IN ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES SO THAT'S A QUICK
SNAPSHOT OF DIFFERENT THAT ARE
LOCAL AND REGIONAL AND STATE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE FROM THE
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM- THAT IS MY
PRESENTATION OPEN FOR QUESTIONS
OR THE NEXT HOUSE. WE WANT TO
MAKE SOMETHING RUMORED SOME
VITIATED SO NOT SO LET'S HEAR
FROM ANNOUNCES ORINDA SCHOOL
SAFETY CONSULTING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA. APARTMENT EDUCATION
ANNOUNCE YOUR EITHER. I VERY
GOOD MORNING. ARE WE CONNECTED
BY OUR YOU ARE ON TWITTER THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR OF THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DISCUSS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND OUR
SAFETY POLICIES THAT HAVE
RESULTED FROM ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN. I'M
NANCY SEVEN DONE EDUCATION
PROGRAMS CONSULTANT IN THE
SCHOOL HEALTH AND SAFETY OFFICE
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
AND I'M PLEASED TO BE HERE
TODAY. AND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
OFFERING THIS VERY IMPACTFUL
LEGISLATION. CALIFORNIA
ALL PUBLIC REGARDING THROUGH
TWELVE SCHOOLS INCLUDING
CHARTER SCHOOLS. I HAVE DEVELOP
ANNUALLY AND UPDATE A
COMPREHENSIVE SCHOOL SAFETY
PATHS WITH NUMEROUS
REQUIREMENTS ON TRANSCRIPTS
HEATERS FOR SCHOOL CLIMATE
PHYSICAL SETTINGS EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND A NUMBER OF
OTHER ITEMS AS BULLYING CHILD
ABUSE PROCEDURES DISCRIMINATION
HATE CRIMES AND MUCH MUCH MORE.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITORS
CONDUCTED AN AUDIT ON SCHOOL
VIOLENCE. PREVENTION IN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS DISTRICTS
AND COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
TOGETHER THEY'RE CALLED LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES FOR L. B.
AS- FINDINGS A RECOMMENDATIONS
REPORT AT THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND
THE STATE MUST DO MORE TO
ENSURE THAT SCHOOL SAFETY
PLANS. HELP PROTECT STUDENTS
AND STAFF DURING EMERGENCIES IT
ALSO REPORTED THAT DISTRICTS
COULD BENEFIT FROM BEST
PRACTICES TO VERIFY PLAN
SUBMISSIONS AND APPROVALS.
ASSEMBLY BILL RESPONDED SWIFTLY
TO THE STATE AUDIT WITH NEW
REQUIREMENTS THAT HAVE ALREADY
STRENGTHENS THE SCHOOL SAFETY
PLANNING PROCESS. THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAS HAD
THREE MAIN REQUIREMENTS FROM
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FORTY
SEVEN. THE FIRST IS FOR CD
EIGHT TO PROVIDE GENERAL
DIRECTION- BUILDING DISASTER
PLANS THAT ARE REQUIRED IN THE
OVERALL PLAN. CDA CONSULT
INTERNALLY WITH OUR FACILITIES
DEFICIENT EXTERNALLY WITH THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
ADAM WITH CALIFORNIA STATE.
BERMAN OF GENERAL SERVICES
DIVISION OF STATE ARCHITECTS
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE ALLIANCE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
DRAFTED GENERAL GUIDANCE BASED
ON THE BEST THINKING OF THESE
AGENCIES. AS FOLLOWS EMERGENCY
PROCEDURES SHOULD BE DEVELOPED
AND ADAPTED TO EACH SCHOOL'S
NEEDS HANDLE AND CIRCUMSTANCES
IN COLLABORATION WITH FIRST
RESPONDERS AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERS IS DISASTER PLANS MAY
INCLUDE FIRE RELOCATION
EVACUATION BOB THREAT
BIOTERRORISM EARTHQUAKES FLOODS
POWER FAILURE INTRUDERS HOSTAGE
WEAPONS EXPLOSION GAS FUMES AND
DISASTER PLANS FOR OUTBREAKS OF
PANDEMIC DISEASES THE GENERAL
WAS. IN FEBRUARY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND THEIR AFTER
ANNUALLY IN THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT LETTER TO THE
FIELD REMINDING ABOUT SCHOOL
SAFETY PLAN UPDATES. THE
POSITIVE OUTCOME FROM THIS ITEM
HAS BEEN THAT ELLIE AS ARE
ASKING FOR MORE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM OUR AGENCIES
ARE COLLABORATING AND MORE
AWARE OF HAZARDS AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS. THAT HAVE HELPED
THEM DEVELOP THESE DISASTER
PLAN. THE SECOND REQUIREMENT
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
HAS BEEN TO DEVELOP AND POST ON
OUR WEBSITE BEST PRACTICES FOR
REVIEWING AND APPROVING SCHOOL
SAFETY PLANS. THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION FELT THIS WAS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY AND A
RESPONSIBILITY TO REACH OUT
DIRECTLY TO OUR CONSTITUENTS TO
OUR- SAFETY PLANNERS AT THE
COUNTY'S. AND IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY WE
SCHEDULE THREE IN PERSON.
MEETINGS FOR INFORMATION
GATHERING AS THEY WORK TO BE A
PLASTER CARD AND ORANGE COUNTY.
DUE TO THE ONSET OF THE
PANDEMIC AND TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS AND ABBAS'S
CLOSING THE CDC WAS NOT ABLE TO
HOLD IN PERSON MEETINGS.
HOWEVER WE SEE WE PRESIDENT
QUICKLY DEVELOPED A
COMPREHENSIVE SURVEY IT WAS
DISSEMINATED TO FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND
TO THEIR CASE SAFETY PERSONNEL.
THE SURVEY WAS NOT REQUIRED BY
THE SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN IT
WAS TO GIVE US MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE REAL NEEDS AND
CHALLENGES IN THE FIELD. HERE I
WILL HIGHLIGHT JUST A FEW
INSIGHTFUL RESULTS FROM THE
SURVEY. NEARLY TWO HUNDRED
RESPONSES THAT REPRESENTED
CENTRAL NORTH AND SOUTH
CALIFORNIA FROM URBAN AND
RURAL. ENTITIES RESPONDED THE
TRAINING EXPERIENCE OF THOSE IN
CHARGE OF EMERGENCY PLANNING
COMPLIANCE HAVE. 18% HAD
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT TRAINING
OR LAW ENFORCEMENT EXPERIENCE
AND MOST OF THE TRAINING
OCCURRED AT THE DISTRICT FOR
THE OTHERS. 47% HELD SCHOOL
SAFETY MEETINGS ON A REGULAR
BASIS THE OTHERS HELP THEM AS
NEEDED OR ONCE ANIMAL. 96%
COLLABORATE WITH THEIR EXTERNAL
AGENCIES. AND LOCAL OFFICES OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES WITH
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS ACTIVE
SHOOTER ADVENTURE TRAVEL AND
OTHER EMERGENCY PLANNING. A
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
GATHER THEIR CRIME AND SAFETY
DATA WHICH IS REQUIRED IN THE
SAFETY PLAN FROM A VARIETY OF
SOURCES MOSTLY LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT SUSPENSION AND
EXPULSION DATA CHILD WELFARE
AND ATTENDANCE OFFICE INSURANCE
PROVIDERS SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICERS AND STUDENT
INFORMATION SYSTEMS. 92% OF THE
L. A. A.'S ENSURE ADEQUATE
FUNCTIONAL ADAPTATIONS FOR
STUDENTS AND STAFF WITH
DISABILITIES. MANY POLICIES
INCLUDE HOW MANY MANY PLANS
INCLUDE POLICIES THAT ARE NOT
REQUIRED BY LAW IT THIS TIME
BEHAVIORAL THREAT ASSESSMENT
TEAMS LOCKDOWN DRILLS ARE TOO
IMPORTANT ONCE. L. SCHOOL
SAFETY AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE
TRAINING OF STAFF AND STUDENTS
VARIES GREATLY AMONG THE
ENTITIES. 4% HAVE REPORTED NON
COMPLIANT SCHOOLS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
THOUGH THIS MAY SOUND LIKE A
SMALL NUMBER IS UP FROM NEARLY
0% PRIOR TO THE STATE AUDIT AND
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN. 86% USE
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
RESOURCES FOR SCHOOL SAFETY
PLANNING. AND OTHERS THAT ARE
USED ARE FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
HELLO YES CAL FIRE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. COMMON OBSTACLES TO
EFFECTIVE SCHOOL SAFETY
PLANNING REPORTED AS LIMITED
STAFF STAFF TURNOVER SAFETY
PLANS THAT ARE CHECKED OFF AND
PUT ON A SHELF NOT PRACTICED
AND NOT IMPLEMENTED EFFECTIVELY
AND LACK OF FUNDING FOR
TRAINING AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. 61% HAVE EMERGENCY
COMMUNICATIONS PLANTS IN
LANGUAGES OTHER THAN ENGLISH.
AND 61% COMMUNICATE SAFETY
INFORMATION TO FAMILIES. IN THE
PARENT HANDBOOK OTHERS BY EMAIL
ANSEM NOTICES GO OUT IN THE
STUDENT BACKPACK EXPRESS. THE
THIRD ITEM THAT THE CITY IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR IS TO MAINTAIN
UPDATE AND POST A COMPLIANCE
CHECKLIST FOR DEVELOPING SCHOOL
SAFETY PLANS. THIS IS AN
OPTIONAL USED TOOL AND IT HAS
BEEN POSTED SINCE AT LEAST
TWENTY FIFTEEN. THE TOOL IS
UPDATED ANNUALLY AND WE'RE
LEGISLATION. COMES ABOUT AND IT
CONTAINS CURRENTLY AND REFERS
TO ALL OF THE REQUIRED ELEMENTS
OF ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN
FORTY SEVEN. POSITIVE OUTCOMES
ON THE COMPLIANCE LIST HAVE
BEEN BAD ALL SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICT AND THE PUBLIC HAVE
ACCESS TO IT. IT IS INTENDED TO
BE USED AS A CHECKLIST. AND IN
CONCLUSION I AM PLEASED TO
REPORT THAT THE CD IS IN FULL
COMPLIANCE WITH ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN. I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M HAPPY
TO RESPOND TO QUESTIONS. THANK
ROADS NANCY SO NOW WE'LL GO ON
TO OUR NEXT A PRISONER CHIEF
JOE JUSTICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE OF AND
UNIVERSITY POLICE CHIEFS THE-
SOCIAL ASIAN- CHIEF ARE YOU
THERE. I'M HERE CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE'RE NEAR. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT- AS YOU'VE JUST
HEARD MY NAME IS JOEL JUSTICE
AND I AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITY POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION. OUR ASSOCIATION
HAS A LONG. HISTORY OF
ADDRESSING CAMPUS SAFETY ISSUES
AND HAS BEEN AN EARLY PROPONENT
OF THE USE OF AN OPERABILITY
TECHNOLOGY IN ADDRESSING
NATIONAL INCIDENTS. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN WE
SPONSORED ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN NINETY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS FLORA COOPER
AND SENATOR. GALGIANI THE BILL
INVOLVED INTO A. FIVE THE
TECHNOLOGY TO ADDRESS MASS
SHOOTER INCIDENTS ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES THE CONCEPT WAS ROOTED
IN THE MARJORY STONEMAN DOUGLAS
HIGH SCHOOL PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMISSION REPORT TO GOVERNOR
SCOTT OF FLORIDA WHICH STATED
THAT NEED FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
OF FIRST RESPONDERS TO STRIVE.
FOR COMMUNICATION AND-
OPERABILITY. IS THIS VERY LACK
OF INTEROPERABLE THE LACK THAT
EXISTS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
EXPONENTIALLY MAGNIFIED THE
TRAGEDY OF MARJORY STONEMAN
DOUGLAS HIGH SCHOOL AS FIRST
RESPONDERS DID NOT RECEIVE REAL
TIME COMMUNICATIONS FROM THE
SCHOOL SITE. THE COMMUNICATIONS
SO DEFICIENT THAT THE SHOOTER
HAD ALREADY KILLED SEVENTEEN
PEOPLE AND LEFT THE CAMPUS BY
THE TIME FIRST RESPONDERS
ARRIVED IN FLORIDA UNLIKE
CALIFORNIA NOW HAS STATEWIDE
GENERAL OPERABILITY TECHNOLOGY
COVERING EVERY COUNTY AND
FLORIDA. WE HAVE WORKED CLOSELY
WITH THE CREATORS AND OPERATORS
OF THE FLORIDA CENTER
OPERABILITY TECHNOLOGY AND
PROVIDED THE NAMES OF THE THREE
FLORIDA LAW ENFORCEMENT PEOPLE
WITH DEEP EXPERIENCE WITH
FLORIDA'S OUR SUCCESSFUL
STRATEGY TO YOUR COMMITTEE.
REPORT THAT THEY WERE NOT
INCLUDED IN TODAY'S HEARING. WE
HAD APPROACHED OUR TWO THOUSAND
AND NINETEEN SUCCESS WITH
HAVING AN OPERABILITY
TECHNOLOGY IN THE BUDGET WITH
GREAT ANTICIPATION AND WE
READILY SHARED OUR EXPERTISE
AND OUR EXPERIENCE WITH FLORIDA
LAW ENFORCEMENT WITH
CALIFORNIA'S- OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES COMPLETELY
IGNORED EVERITT WHAT WITH THE
RESULT THAT CALIFORNIA UNLIKE
FLORIDA DOES NOT HAVE
TECHNOLOGY THAT PROTECTS OUR
SCHOOLS WE HAVE FILED A
NARRATIVE OF OUR INTERACTION
WITH- YES WITH YOUR COMMITTEE.
NOTWITHSTANDING THE SETBACKS
PARCELS HE REMAINS COMMITTED TO
THE USE OF THEIR OPERABILITY
TECHNOLOGY- THAT WILL ENHANCE
SCHOOL SAFETY AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARD THE
EVENTUAL ACHIEVEMENT OF THAT
GOAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- CHIEF NOW WILL
GO ON TO OUR NEXT. PRESENTER OR
WILL BE LOOKING FOR A- TRAINING
PROGRAM SERVER SUBROTO CHIEF
MIKE RADFORD WITH THE
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING- MIKE
ARE YOU THERE. YES I AM CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN RESIDENTS
IN THE COMMITTEE. BY THE
COMMISSION PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING WAS
ESTABLISHED BY LEGISLATORS IN
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE TO SET
MINIMUM SELECTION TRAINING
STANDARDS FOR CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT. BOTH PROGRAM IS
VOLUNTARY INCENTIVE BASED
PARTICIPATING AGENCIES DO AGREE
TO ABIDE BY THE STANDARDS
ESTABLISHED BY POST ONE SIX
AGENCIES PARTICIPATE IN THE
POST PROGRAM ARE ELIGIBLE TO
RELIEF TO RECEIVE THE
COMMISSION'S SERVICES BENEFITS.
SPECIFICALLY TO THE TRAINING
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
RECEIVED. ACTIVE SHOOTER. A
FIRST WILL DISCUSS THE REGULAR
BASIC ACADEMY TRAINING.
ALERTING DOMAIN TWENTY THREE.
IN PROGRESS IS A TWENTY HOUR
SECTION. ONE OF ONE PART OF THE
TRAINING. THAT HAS A TESTING
TRAINING STANDARD REQUIREMENT
STUDENTS MUST DEMONSTRATE.
OFFICER'S ACTIONS WITH SAVING
TACKLE RESPONSE INVOLVING RAPID
DEPLOYMENT TO A DELI COUNTER OR
ACTIVE SHOOTER. LEARNING
INCLUDES DEFINING A RAPID
DEPLOYMENT AND AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER WHEN DEPLOY AND FIRST
RESPONDER CONSIDERATIONS SUCH
AS CONTACTING WRITTEN
RESPONSIBILITIES RESCUE TEAM
RESPONSIBILITIES AND WHAT TO
EXPECT. LEARNING TO MAKE TWENTY
THREE HAS A MINIMUM REQUIREMENT
OF TWENTY HOURS TO BE TAUGHT
COLLECTIVELY. A SECOND WE'LL
TALK ABOUT IN SERVICE TRAINING.
BUT THERE IS NO REGULATORY OR
LEGISLATIVE MANDATE ACTIVE
SHOOTER TRAINING BE CONDUCTED.
SO ACTIVE SHOOTER TRAININGS
LEFT UP TO THE DISCRETION OF
INDIVIDUAL AGENCIES. CURRENT
ACTIVE SHOOTER TRAINING COURSES
THAT ARE POST CERTIFIED OR
ACTIVE SHOOTER INSTRUCTOR
ACTIVE SHOOTER RESPONSE ACTIVE
SHOOTER RESPONSE UPDATE. ACTIVE
SHOOTER OR VIOLENT INTRUDERS.
DISPATCHER AS YET BUT INVOLVES
ACTIVE SHOOTER SITUATIONS MULTI
DISCIPLINE RESPONSE TO ACTIVE
SHOOTER. TOPICAL EMERGENCY
FIRST AID OR TRAUMA CARE.
DISPATCH TERRORISM AWARENESS IN
TERRORISM AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
RESPONSE. FOR THESE COURSES ARE
PRESENTED BY DIFFERENT AGENCIES
ARE PRISONERS WHO SUBMIT A
COURSE OR POST CERTIFICATION
AND IS OPEN TO ALMOST ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL. ACTIVE
SHOOTER COURSES PRIMARILY
CONTAIN BUT ARE NOT LIMITED TO
THE FOLLOWING LEARNING
OBJECTIVES. AND POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES MOVEMENT AND TACTICS
RESCUE PROCEDURES. TABCORP
MEDICAL EVALUATION CARE AND
UNIFIED OR INCIDENT COMMITTED.
I SPECIFICALLY TWO AB FIFTEEN
NINETY EIGHT OR NOW ARE WHAT IS
COLLECTIVELY KNOWN AT OR IN
PEOPLE COULD JUST THIRTEEN FIVE
ONE NINE POINT TWO SEVEN AND
INTO SOUTH AND TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN PER LEGISLATION POST
WAS REQUIRED TO DEVELOP A
COURSE INSTRUCTION THAT
INCLUDES CRITERIA FOR THE
CURRICULUM CONTENT INVOLVING
THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF FIRST
RESPONDERS TO TERRORISM THE
BATES TO THE FOLLOWING CRITERIA
WAS DEVELOPED BY PUBLIC AND IS
CURRENTLY IN AFFECTED
REGULATION. OVERVIEW OF
CONVENTIONAL CHEMICAL
BIOLOGICAL RADIOACTIVE
RADIOLOGICAL BAKER DISCLOSED
ADVICES. IN HAZARD RECOGNITION
UNDERSTANDING THE STRUCTURE AND
FUNCTION OF AN INCIDENT COMMAND
SYSTEM. INITIAL RESPONSE
ACTIONS INCLUDING PRIMARY
ASSESSMENTS NOTIFICATIONS
RESOURCE NEEDS AND SAFETY
CONSIDERATIONS. COORDINATION
WITH OTHER EMERGENCY SERVICES
FIRST RESPONDERS. GATHERING
VERIFYING ASSESSING AND
COMMUNICATING INCIDENT
INFORMATION UNDERSTANDING MASK
HAS LIMITATIONS AND
DECONTAMINATION REQUIREMENTS
BALANCING LIFESAVING ACTIVITIES
WITH- WITH EVIDENCE
PRESERVATION AND GENERAL
AWARENESS TO ADDITIONAL
TRAINING FOR EACH OF THE FIRST
RESPONDER CATEGORIES SPECIFIC
TO EACH DISCIPLINE. AND SO
FINALLY I TALK A LITTLE BIT THE
TOTAL INVOLVED A TOTAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TRAINED IN
ACTIVE SHOOTER TRAINING- HELLO
FORSMAN OFFICERS AND SINCE
FISCAL YEAR TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN IN THE AREAS THAT
SPECIFICALLY ARE DISCUSSED IN
AB FIFTEEN NINETY EIGHT WE CALL
THAT WE HAVE IT UNDER THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESPONSE TO
TERRORISM- THERE'S FIVE TOTAL
CLASSES. THAT REFLECT THAT
PARTICULAR- SO WE BUILT IN A
TOTAL SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN OF SIXTEEN THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED. AND THIRTY SIX LONG
COURSE MOFFETT OFFICERS HAVE
PARTICIPATED. EXACTLY ARE TALK
ABOUT ACTIVE SHOOTER AS A WHOLE
SINCE. TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
THERE ARE SIX ACTIVE SHOOTER
COURSES THAT ARE CURRENTLY.
ACTIVE IN POST REVOCATION. AND
AS OF TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN TILL
CURRENT THERE HAS BEEN TWENTY
ONE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WHO HAVE PARTICIPATED
IN THAT PARTICULAR POST
TRAINING. THIS DOESN'T INCLUDE
ANY NON CLOSER TO FIGHT TRADING
WHICH AGENCIES PARTICIPATE IN
DURING THEIR OWN OR THEIR OWN
REGIONAL STYLE TRADING THAT MAY
NOT BE CLOSER TO FIVE. THE
INFORMATIONAL YIELDED F. FOR
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH UNEX WILL GO ON
TO OUR NEXT PRESENTER LUIS
BRANCO CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
EMSA. ARE YOU AVAILABLE THE LOS.
I AM GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
COLLEAGUES MY NAME IS LOUIS
BRONCHI I'M THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES%
AUTHORITY. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. AS WE'VE HEARD TODAY
FROM PREVIOUS SPEAKERS TACKLE
INCIDENT RESPONSE TO VITAMIN
PRESENTS UNIQUE CHALLENGES TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL AND
PERSONNEL PROVIDING EMERGENCY
MEDICAL CARE AND SUPPORT
SERVICES IN THAT ENVIRONMENT.
KHALKHAL MEDICAL CARE PROVIDERS
MUST HAVE A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING
OF IN CONSIDERATION FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESPONSE AND
TACTICS AND MISSION SPECIFIC
OBJECTIVES FOR TACTICAL
OPERATION ONE TWENTY FOUR AND
PROVIDING MEDICAL SUPPORT. THE
PRIMARY GOAL OF TACTICAL
MEDICINE IS TO SUPPORT AND
ASSIST THE TACTICAL TEAM IN
ACCOMPLISHING ITS MISSION
DURING OF DEPLOYMENT OR
RESPONSE TO A CRITICAL INCIDENT.
CALIFORNIA RECEIVE MEDICAL
SERVICES A PARTY PROVIDES
OVERSIGHT AND REGULATION TO THE
PROVISION OF EMERGENCY MEDICAL
CARE AND EMS TRAINING. THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING OR OR
POST AND AM SO PROVIDED IT
ESSENTIAL LINK BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND EMERGENCY
MEDICAL CARE. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE POST THROUGH A PARTNERSHIP
WITH ANSWER RELEASED THE
TACTICAL MEDICINE GUIDELINES
PROPER'S OPERATIONAL PROGRAMS
AND STANDARD SIDE. STANDARDIZED
TRAINING FOR LAW. HE FORCING
OFFICERS SUPERVISORS
ADMINISTRATORS ASSIGNED TO
PERFORM SUPERVISE OR MANAGE
THEIR SPECIAL WEAPONS AND
TACTICS OR SWAT TEAMS.
ACCORDING TO THE CALL WILL BE A
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCY DEVELOPING
AN ETEXT TACTICAL MEDICINE
MEDICINE OPERATION PROGRAM
CONDUCTS A NEEDS ASSESSMENT TO
DETERMINE THE LEVEL OF
EMERGENCY CARE REQUIRED BY THE
SWAT TEAM TO SUPPORT THE
MISSION AND OPERATIONS. THE
OPERATIONAL PROGRAM SHOULD
ADDRESS MEDICAL OVERSIGHT AND
COORDINATION WITH LOCAL BMS
AGENCY MEDICAL DIRECTION. USE
OF EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TECHNICIANS PARAMEDICS AND
OTHER ADVANCED LIFE SUPPORT
PERSONNEL AND MINIMUM TRAINING
AND EQUIPMENT STANDARDS. A
COMPREHENSIVE TACTICAL MEDICINE
OPERATIONAL PROGRAM THAT IS
DEVELOPED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES SHOULD HAVE THE
FOLLOWING SEVEN COMPONENTS AS
PART OF ITS PLANNING OPERATIONS
AND EVALUATION PROCESS MEDICAL
OVERSIGHT. MEDICAL CONTINGENCY
PLANNING. OPERATIONAL SUPPORT
TACTICAL EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SUPPORT OR TENS QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT. TEAM HEALTH
MANAGEMENT TRAINING AND
EDUCATION. AND TROUBLED MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT ACQUISITION AND
MAINTENANCE. YOU MUST BE AND
LOCAL EMS AGENCIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MONITORING AND
APPROVING TACTICAL MEDICINE
TRAINING PROGRAMS TRAINING
PROGRAMS OR COURSES
ADMINISTERED BY STATEWIDE
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES SUCH AS-
OPPOSED. TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION CALVARY AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY FOR. ARE APPROVED BY
THE AT FORTY. TRAIN OR COURSES
A BY ANY ENTITY ARE APPROVED BY
THE LOCAL EMS AGENCY THAT HAS
JURISDICTION WITHIN THE AREA IN
WHICH THE PROGRAM FOR COURSE IS
HEADQUARTERED. IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN LEGISLATURE ENACTED AB
FIFTEEN NINETY EIGHT. AB
FIFTEEN NINETY EIGHT ESTABLISH
THE PROTOCOLS AND TRAINING FOR
RESPONSE TO ACTIVE SHOOTER
INCIDENTS MUST BE ESTABLISHED
LOCALLY TO WORK WITHIN THE
RESOURCES AND LIMITATIONS OF
EACH JURISDICTION. PURSUANT TO
HEALTH AND SAFETY SECTION
SEVENTY NINETY SEVEN OF ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN THE M. AS
OF THIRTY DEVELOP THE
CALIFORNIA TACTICAL CASUALTY
CARE TRAINING GUIDELINES IN
JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
AB FIFTEEN NINETY EIGHT STATED
THAT THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT TO
DO THE FOLLOWING FIRST REQUIRE
THE DEVELOPMENT OF
COLLABORATIVE PROTOCOLS AND
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN LOCAL AND
STATE FIRST RESPONSE EIGHT
ENTITIES. INCLUDING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES FIRE
DEPARTMENTS AND EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICE PROVIDERS IN
ORDER THAT THOSE ENTITIES SHALL
ACT EFFECTIVELY AND IN CONCERT
TO. ADDRESS ACTIVE SHOOTER
INCIDENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
SECOND REQUIRE FIRST RESPONSE
ENTITIES TO SEE COLLABORATIVE
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
TABLE TOP OR SIMULATION
EXERCISES. TO ASSESS PLAN
IMPLEMENTATIONS AND TO INCLUDE
OTHER ENTITIES THAT MAY BE
INVOLVED IN AFTER ACTIVE
SHOOTER INCIDENTS. IN THOSE
TRAININGS SUCH AS SCHOOLS CITY
OR COUNTY PERSONNEL AND PRIVATE
BUSINESSES. AND FINALLY REQUIRE
THAT THE BASIC AND ONGOING
TRAINING FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY PERSONNEL FIRE
DEPARTMENT PERSONNEL EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES PERSONNEL AND
THE PERSONNEL FOR OTHER FIRST
RESPONSE RESPOND RISEN INCLUDE.
AS APPROPRIATE. TRAINING
EDUCATION ON EDUCATION ON
ACTIVE SHOOTER INCIDENTS AND
TACTICAL CASUALTY CARE. IT WAS
ALSO THE STATED INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE THAT EACH FIRST
RESPONSE ENTITY IN
COLLABORATION WITH OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES FIRE
DEPARTMENTS EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES PROVIDERS DEVELOP
PROTOCOLS FOR RESPONDING TO
ACTIVE SHOOTER INCIDENTS. THOSE
PROTOCOLS MUST BE REVIEWED
ANNUALLY TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE CURRENT AND ADDRESS ANY
POLICY GEOGRAPHIC OR
DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGES THAT
WARRANT A RESPONSE STRATEGY
REVIEW. THE LEGISLATURE
INTENDED THAT THE PROTOCOLS
ADDRESSED ALL OF THE FOLLOWING.
ROLES RESPONSIBILITIES AND
POLICIES OF EACH ENTITY
RESPONDING TO AN ACTIVE SHOOTER
INCIDENT. YES CONTINGENCY
PLANNING THAT INCLUDES
IDENTIFICATION OF POTENTIAL
TARGETS WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTION. IMPLEMENTATION OF
AN INCIDENT COMMAND SYSTEM OR
ICS INCLUDE EMERGENCY PROTOCOLS
WERE UNIFIED COMMAND STRUCTURE
FOR AND HE'S RESPONDING TO AN
ACTIVE SHOOTER INCIDENT.
INTERAGENCY COMMUNICATIONS
ISSUES AND NEEDS INCLUDING BUT
NOT LIMITED TO RADIO IN OUR
OPERABILITY AND ESTABLISHMENT
OF A COMMON LANGUAGE TERMS AND
DEFINITIONS TO BE USED. ON THE
SCENE OF AN ACTIVE SHOOTER
INCIDENT. IDENTIFICATION OF
RESOURCES FOR RESPONDING TO AN
ACTIVE SHOOTER INCIDENT
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
PRIMARY AND SECONDARY NEEDS AND
HOSPITAL'S. TACTICAL DEPLOYMENT
OF AVAILABLE RESOURCES FOR
RESPONDING TO AN ACTIVE SHOOTER
INCIDENT AND FINALLY RECEIVED
TREATMENT AN EXTRA EXTRACTION
OF PERSONS INJURED IN AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER INCIDENT. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. I
ALSO DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF OUR
DISASTER MEDICAL SERVICES
DIVISION. GREG JOHNSON LOOK
FORWARD TO ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE. OKAY THANK YOU I KNOW
WE HAD THAT CRAIG JOHNSON- SO
HE WAS NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
PRESENT TODAY. BUT TAKEN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN- CRAIG IS
STANDING BY TO IT TO. SEE HOW
TO ANSWER OKAY BUT STUDENTS.
ARE YAK REGARD DID YOU WANT TO
ADD ANYTHING TO- WHAT YOUR
FOLKS DOING THERE AT MCM. UNDER
YOUR OUR LAST PRESENTER SO JUST
WANTED TO SHARE IF WE HAD
ANYTHING YOU WANTED AFTER. SURE
SURE WELL FIRST OF ALL GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
VICE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. R. MR LEWIS BRONCHI
REALLY COVERED IT WELL FOR THE
INNOCENT FORTY SO I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING MORE TO ADD. BUT
CERTAINLY IN HERE TO ASSIST
WITH ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND ONCE
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY- ON BOTH PANELS FOR
ALL YOUR TIME IN. YOUR
PRESENTATIONS TODAY I THINK
IT'S BEEN VERY EDUCATED NOT
ONLY TO MYSELF BUT TO SOME OF
THE MEMBERS HERE OF. THE
COMMITTEE OBVIOUSLY WE'VE DONE
A LOT FOR THE LAST COUPLE YEARS
A LOT OF LESSONS LEARNED FROM.
UNFORTUNATELY THESE TERRIBLE
ATTACKS THAT HAPPEN- AND
SOMETIMES THEY HAVE OBVIOUSLY
THEY ALWAYS HAPPEN UNEXPECTEDLY
I KNOW THAT WE'VE BEEN HEARING
A LOT ABOUT IN OPERABILITY
COMMUNICATIONS IS ONE OF THE-
CHALLENGES WITH SOME OF THESE
AGENCIES AND ALL. EVERYBODY
COMES FROM DIFFERENT AREAS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT- WE CAN
ADDRESS A LOT OF THE ISSUES
THAT YOU TALK ABOUT- ONE OF THE
BIGGEST TAKEAWAYS I ORDERED ONE
OF THE VEGAS- THINGS I WANT TO
PUT IN EVERYBODY'S- ON. A PLATE
IS ANYTHING ELSE WE CAN DO AT
THE STATE LEVEL TO HELP. YOU IN
YOUR OFFICES YOUR DEPARTMENTS
TO BETTER PREPARE OR PLAN FOR
THESE TYPES OF INCIDENTS AND I
KNOW WE'VE TALKED ABOUT A LOT
OF THINGS. BUT ANYTHING THAT
KIND OF STICKS OUT OF ANYBODY'S
MIND THAT SOMETHING WE SHOULD
FOCUS ON HERE JUST WANT TO OPEN
UP TO. ANYBODY ON EITHER PANEL
THAT- WE MAY NOT HAVE TALKED
ABOUT OR MAYBE. SOMETHING IN
OUR FROM OUR SECOND PROMISED A
MAY HAVE- BROUGHT TO OUR
ATTENTION. SO IS THERE ANYTHING
OUT THERE FROM ANYBODY THAT WE
MAY HAVE MISSED OR- SOMETHING-
THAT. WE SHOULD REALLY FOCUS ON
HERE AT THE STATE LEVEL. AND K.
R. ONE THING I ONE THING I
WANTED TO ADD TO HIS WELL I
KNOW THERE'S BEEN TALK
REGARDING A STOP THE BLEED-
JUST WANTED TO. KIND OF PUT IT
OUT THERE WITH FOLKS I KNOW.
THERE'S BEEN A PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION REGARDING. THE
PLACEMENT OF AEDS MY THINK OF
WE LOOK AT ANY BUILDING OR MALL
OR WHEREVER WE MAY GO TO. WE C.
A. E. D.'S PLACED IN CERTAIN
AREAS OF THE BUILDINGS- WHAT'S-
ANYBODY'S THOUGHTS IF- IT WOULD
BE NICE TO. PUT A STOP THE
BLEED TYPE OF PACKED NEXT TO
THE A. E. D.'S. THAT WOULD HELP
JUST THE GENERAL A PERSON
THAT'S IN THAT BUILDING IN THAT
AREA. THAT IF AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER. INCIDENT DOES OCCUR.
THAT THERE ARE WHERE OF- THESE
TYPES OF PACKS THERE THAT CAN
HELP CONTROL BLEEDING BECAUSE
AS WE KNOW- THE- THIS THIS
QUICK AS WE CAN STOP THE BLEED
ON INDIVIDUALS THE BETTER
CHANCE WE DO OUT SAVINGA LIFE
SO. WHAT'S ANYBODY'S THOUGHTS
ON THAT- WOULD YOU THINK THAT
WOULD BE SOMETHING WE SHOULD
LOOK AT- AT THE STATE LEVEL TO.
ADD TO THESE A E. D. SAID THAT.
STOP THE B. TYPE OF PACKED-
ANYBODY'S THOUGHTS ARE ON THAT.
THIS IS CHIEF IF I CAN WEIGH IN
ON. SURE ORCHARD. BELT WILL BE
A HUGE. HELP TO NOT ONLY GOOD
TO THE CITIZENS ON SCENE BUT
ALSO THE FIRST RESPONDERS
COMING AND- SO JUST TO PUT THAT
IN BOUNDS WE CARE OUR POINT OF
OUR PAL KIDS THOSE LITTLE
FINANCIAL WHERE EACH ONE WILL
HAVE TEN TOURNIQUETS IT BUT IF
YOU GET RID OF IT LIKE LAS
VEGAS WITH THE- IT AROUND SO
ADDING IN- TOURNIQUETS IN CHEST
SEALS ALONG WITH THE EIGHTIES
AND MAJOR ASSEMBLY AREAS WOULD
BE A HUGE HELP TO NOT ONLY
FIRST RESPONDERS TO STOP THE
BLEED BUT ALSO. IF WE RUN OUT
OF SUPPLIES WE CAN DIG INTO
THAT AS WELL WHICH- IS REALLY A
POSSIBILITY WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE LARGE NUMBERS LAS VEGAS I
THINK WAS LIKE OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED VICTIMS IN LESS THAN
TEN MINUTES- SO YOU COULD SAVE
A TON OF LIVES WITHOUT WITH
MINIMAL COST AND- MAKING A
STANDARD CASH WITH THE
EIGHTIES- THEY'RE FAIRLY SIMPLE
TO PUT ON FOR CIVILIANS. AND AS
WE GO FROM THE VIETNAM ONE
STUDY THAT YOU ALL ARE GOING TO
KEEP SENDING VICTIMS IN THE
FIRST FIVE MINUTES FROM A
DRAMATIC SHOT THAT CAN MAKE A
HUGE DIFFERENCE TO AN EXTREMELY
WANT. OKAY THANK FOR MUCH YOU
FOR YOUR FOR YOUR INPUT ON THAT
SO WITHOUT- OBVIOUSLY I WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY FOR
PARTICIPATING REALLY THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN FOR ALL THE HARD
WORK YOU DO ALL YOUR DEPARTMENT
YOU WORK OUT ESPECIALLY ONCE
AGAIN TO OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
THAT ARE OUT THERE DAY IN AND
DAY OUT- THE RUSH TO EIGHT FOR
THOSE FOLKS IN NEED. SO NOW I
WANT TO TURN OVER TO OUR
OPERATOR- TO SWELL FIRST WON'T
OPEN UP TO- OUR ANY MEMBERS
HERE OR ANY FOLKS IN PERSON YOU
WOULD LIKE TO- OUT FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. I BELIEVE THERE NOBODY
IN THE ROOM FOR COMMENT. SO
THAT WILL TO OPT. OPERATORS ARE
ANY ON THE ANYONE ON THE LINE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF ANYONE WISHES
TO COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME FOR YOUR
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO
MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE
KNOWS SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK. OKAY THANK YOU
OPERATOR WE'LL SEE THAT WE HAVE
NO ONE ON THE LINE AND ONCE
AGAIN NO ONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM FOR PUBLIC COMMENT- WANT
TO THANK EVERYBODY ONCE AGAIN
FOR IT TO SPENDING TODAY AND
WITHOUT THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED. THANK YOU.